72, also Chaosradio, wie man hören kann, 72, weil wir was gesagt haben. Du hast die CD mit dem Opener vergessen, Frank.
Ja, keiner war da, der sie uns geben konnte.
Ich hab von Paul, von Kollegen von Dück, hab ich eine CD geliehen gekriegt jetzt. Die fängt ungefähr so an wie das Chaosradio auch. Also wir machen das jetzt einfach mal und melden uns dann gleich. Womit wir uns dann gleich melden. Guck mal, fängt an wie Chaosradio.
Das sind die abgestürzten Server im Keller.
Ja, bis gleich. Chaosradio 72 hier auf Fritz, einen wunderschönen guten Abend. Interessiert jemand, was das für Musik war? Ah, danke, danke, dass du mich weißt. Jolly Music, Radio, Jolly im Original Nix. Hat Paul mir hier gelassen, ja. Wollen wir mal anfangen?
Verhält mir noch jemanden, wie ich diese Uhr hier am Rechner stellen kann. Irritiert mich total, dass sie drei Minuten vorgeht.
Ja, das ist, ne, das ist, das ist...
Windows NT und ich darf nicht.
NT-Ortszeit. Chaosradio 72 im Studio Frank und... Ich hab deinen Namen schon wieder verges... Sarah. Hey, Sarah. Genau. Frank und Sarah. An den Reglern steht Holger Klein, wie meistens. Und die Musik, die Musik, die kommt von LN.
Genau, von LN. Richtig.
Und die macht im Hintergrund schon Sachen. Warum knistert das denn so? Wie was?
Was ist das denn?
Voll analog.
Irgendwie knistert das. Das ist ein Vinyl.
Oder der kaputte Server am Klappen.
Der ist nicht kaputt, der ist nur ein bisschen, der ist der feuchte. Das hört sich aber komisch an. Es hat ja einen guten Grund, dass wir Chaosradio heißen. Fang mal an, bitte.
Die Ellen ist nämlich auch zu hören und zu sehen bei der großen Deckerton-Nacht, in der Nacht des Horrors in München, bzw. Quatschung in Regensburg am 31. Mai im Suite 15 und am 1. Juli im Ultraschall in München. Und die wird jetzt die nächsten drei Stunden für uns eine nette Hintergrund- und Vordergrundmusik und Ermalung machen.
Na ja, wir können ja einfach schon mal anfangen, so ein bisschen zu erzählen, worum es heute geht. Oder Frank, willst du erstmal mit den Chaos-Nachrichten anfangen? Der letzte Monat?
Nee, erzähl doch mal ganz kurz, warum es sich lohnt, heute dran zu bleiben, die Themen.
Also es lohnt sich bestimmt dran zu bleiben, denn wir haben ein paar tolle Stories über Bonusprogramme und Happy Digits und fühlen der ganzen Sache mal auf den Zahn. Was denn dahinter steckt, wenn man in der Bahn sitzt und jedes Mal gefragt wird, ob man nicht auch Punkte sammeln möchte.
Genau, die Pupsipunkte zum Beispiel.
Genau, die Pupsipunkte, weil man irgendwie, man fährt jeden Tag mit der Bahn und hat jeden Tag die gleiche Frage auf dem Tuch und irgendwann nervt es einfach. Naja, und ich glaube, da gehen wir mal ein bisschen hinter die Kulissen und sprechen auch mal mit den Leuten, die die Big Brother Awards für schon derartige Punkteprogramme vergeben haben. Ja, dann wollten wir noch ein bisschen über Data Mining, über Web Mining und über Kundensegmentierung, über Marketing sprechen.
Kundensegmentierung? Ja, das macht man mit so großen Schwertern, mit großen scharfen Schwertern.
Wir sind heute auf dem BWL-Trip. Ja, genau. Und dann haben wir ja noch, dann wollten wir auf jeden Fall natürlich auch noch auf Web Mining eingehen und auf Schutztechnologien im Internet, Anonymisierungsdienste, Cookie-Management-Systeme. Also da haben wir eine ganze Menge vor. Also inhaltlich ganz schön fett heute.
Genau, dazu muss ich sagen, dass der Sendungstitel Verdaten und verkauft. Das war von unserem 12. Chaos Communication Kongress eigentlich auch der Titel. Also selbst damals war das schon, das war, oh Gott, jetzt muss ich rechnen, 12 jetzt. Da war das schon aktuell und da war einfach so dieser Datenschutzbegriff oder meine Daten und die Firmen, das war damals schon noch aktuell.
Ich mein Datenschutz an sich ist ja schon seit Anfang der 80er Jahre eigentlich aktuell. Damals zu den Volkszählungen, da sind die Leute ja wirklich auf die Barrikanen gegangen. Also wegen zehn Datensätzen haben sich damals in Hamburg über 50 Bürgerinitiativen gegründet und dieses Recht auf informationelle Selbstbestimmung durchgesetzt.
Das stimmt, ich hab immer den Spaß gemacht, auf der Taz-CD-ROM im Archiv mal den Begriff Volkszählung einfach eingegeben. Und ich hatte einfach einen ganzen Abend Spaß. Wie viel Hitz? Die haben 50, 60 oder sowas. Und da haben die Leute Blumentöpfe auf die Zähler geworfen, die haben die irgendwie mit Dreck bespritzt. Es gab dann zum Schluss Straßensperren, wo sie die Bußgelder, die Versäumnisbußgelder für die Leute, die da nicht mitgemacht haben, dann damit eingesammelt haben. Das ist so unglaublich, ich war damals ein bisschen zu jung, um das richtig voll mitzukriegen, aber ich weiß, dass ich irgendwie diesen, also meine Eltern waren jetzt unbedingt, hätten jetzt nicht so jeden Quatsch mitgemacht bis zum Äußersten, aber ich hab dann mein Zettel schon so ausgeführt, dass ich irgendwie verheiratet und sechs Kinder.
Das haben meine Eltern auch gemacht, die eigentlich super bürgerlich sind, so Schrankwand und sowas. Ich weiß nicht, was ihr denn wisst, wir haben sieben Kinder, alle elf.
Das ist echt klasse.
Also meine Theorie war ja damals, oder ist jetzt mittlerweile, dass sie damals eigentlich nur davon ablenken wollten, wie viel Daten tatsächlich schon existieren. Da haben die Leute diesen Fragebogen gesehen, haben gesagt, naja, ist ja gar nicht so schlimm. Und haben gedacht, okay, wenn es alles ist, kriegen sie. Und in Wirklichkeit dient es eigentlich nur davon abzulenken, sowas für Daten überhaupt schon gespeichert. Selbst damals schon 1989.
Ich hab auf dem Land gelebt, da sind die mehr später erst gekommen. Chaosradio 72 auf Fritz, Musik von LN wo ihr die Live erleben könnt. Das klingt eigentlich auch sehr gut, was sie macht. Das liegt nur daran, dass die der eine oder andere ja vielleicht schon mitbekommen hat. Der Keller, der bei Fritz voll gelaufen ist und zwar voll Wasser. Und wir darum praktisch unsere gesamte technische Infrastruktur verloren haben, die wir zum Senden brauchen. Aber wir halten durch. Also im Moment empfangt ihr uns übrigens über Dosentelefon.
Ah genau, noch eine Sache. Wegen dieser besagten Panne im Keller. Wäre es ganz nett, wenn von euch da draußen irgendwie jemand das Ganze hier als MP3 oder so aufnehmen kann.
Ja, das wäre natürlich auch noch ganz ganz toll.
Also klappt ja immer nicht alles so, wie man sich das wünscht. Aber ich hab's probiert vor der Sendung da jemanden zu organisieren. Aber diejenigen waren auch gerade auf dem Weg zum Flughafen und naja, mal gucken. Also es wäre klasse, wenn ihr das irgendwie hinkriegt und uns dann eine Mail schickt und zwar und wir haben es geschafft, wir haben nämlich für jede Sendung jetzt eine eigene E-Mail Adresse, also einen eigenen Verteiler. Weil ihr werdet schon gemerkt haben, also wer uns mal versucht hat, eine Mail zu schreiben, hat sich bestimmt gewundert, da kommt ja sowieso nichts zurück. Das wollen wir jetzt ein bisschen anders machen, dass wir nämlich für jede Sendung eine einzelne Mail Adresse haben. Und das ist diesmal die 72 at chaosradio.ccc.de. Da schickt ihr eure Fragen, Kommentare und sowas zur Sendung hin. Und bei der nächsten Sendung ist dann eben die 73 at chaosradio.ccc.de und so weiter. So, und ich hab ein bisschen was zusammengesammelt, was im letzten Monat bei uns so aufgelaufen ist, an Infos, was so uns Erwähnungswürdiges passiert ist.
Fangen wir mal mit Kim an.
Genau, unser Freund Kim.
Kann ich jetzt dessen Klamotten haben eigentlich?
Die Headline der Woche.
Genau, dann fangen wir doch mit den Sachen von heute an. Ich hab mir nämlich auf dem Weg hierher wieder ein buntes Boulevard Magazin mitgebracht. Und es ist toll, wie man eigentlich aus Tagesthemen immer wieder so ein bisschen was Clubrelevantes rausziehen kann. Zum Beispiel sagt jetzt der BND dann auch, bin Laden lebt. Das heißt, sie hat jetzt auch mal die Zeitungen und die Spiegelartikel alle durch. Und weiß jetzt auch, dass bin Laden möglicherweise lebt. Dann hat der Bundesrechnungshof herausgefunden, dass der Transrapid unrentabel ist.
Was hat der Bundesrechnungshof herausgefunden?
Dazu muss ich sagen, es gibt eine schöne Geschichte dazu, zu diesen Kalkulationen zum Transrapid. Und zwar ging es über die Presseverteiler und so ein Dokument, was dann auch ein Journalist gekriegt hat. Und der Journalist hat in seinem Microsoft Word Programm mal die Funktion Änderungen sichtbar machen. Änderungen im Dokument sichtbar machen aktiviert und hat dann irgendwie ein paar nette Sachen gefunden. Zum Beispiel, dass die Zahlen, die darauf hinweisen würden, dass die Kalkulation eben nicht aufgeht, noch nachträglich rausgelöscht wurden. Das sieht man, das ist halt so rot durchgestrichen und standardmäßig ist die Funktion Änderung Zurückverfolgen bei diesem Programm wohl aktiviert.
Ja, aber Microsoft hat doch sowas gut, ne?
Genau. Und der Journalist hat sich ein bisschen gewundert und das hieß dann wohl auch nur von den Leuten, die die Studie geschrieben haben. Na ja, das waren dann geringfügige redaktionelle Änderungen. Okay.
Da muss man wahnsinnig aufpassen bei diesen Änderungsnachverfolgungsfunktionen. Das kann bitter sein, auch schon mal irgendwelche Gutachten, die dann geschrieben werden und oder irgendwelche Zeugnisse und dann stellt man hinterher fest, der Chef wollte ja eigentlich was ganz anderes machen.
Das ist doch klasse, lass uns das mal nicht so laut sagen, damit wir noch ein bisschen Spaß haben die nächsten Jahre.
Genau, dann ist in der Handelsvertretung der chinesischen Botschaft ein Diplomaten Mercedes geklaut worden.
Den hat bestimmt Kim geklaut jetzt.
Sehr unauffällig mit so einem Kennzeichen noch rumzufahren. Es hat aber den Vorteil, dass man möglicherweise auch durch Straßensperren einfach durchkommt oder in gewisse sensible Bereiche.
In dem Fall sind man einfach ein paar von den Kanonen aus dem Kofferraum, sich einen Weg frei zu schießen.
Also falls ihr mit einem schwarzen Mercedes mit... naja. Dann haben wir hier... so ist sie im Bett... nein, das ist falsch.
Ist er denn auch mit Goldbeschlägen irgendwie und ein bisschen mit Video-Korner drüben und solche Geschichten?
Das ist ja von der chinesischen Botschaft und die haben ja immer so Standarden an der Seite. Da hängen allerdings keine Fahnen, sondern Demokraten dran.
Genau, die Zeitung hat auch Fernseher rausgesucht, wo ich mit dir stehe, die Fußball-WM im Büro gucken kann, also kleine transportable Dinge.
Ja, mit DotWins auch jetzt.
Das Wichtigste haben sie natürlich nicht erwähnt, nämlich die TV-Karte. Die baue ich einfach in den Rechner ein, dann kriege ich den Chef gar nicht mit, dass ich die WM vergesse.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich habe nämlich hier noch genäulich gelesen, dass Fußball gucken am Arbeitsplatz ein fristloser Kündigungsgrund sein kann.
Nur SAP darf das. Aber die müssen nämlich am Rechner wohl gucken. Die haben da irgendwie was gemacht. Ein deutscher Bulle zeugte 17.000 Nachkommen.
Die waren doch alle beim Buschbesuch hier.
Die brauchen keine Bewerbung mehr schreiben. Nein, das handelt sich dabei nicht. Und wir haben hier noch ein Cargolifter. Nein, bei Aldi gibt es einen DVD-Player für 135 Euro, der auch MP3 und Audio CDs abspielen kann.
Aber wenn es den bei Aldi für 135 gibt, gibt es die nächste Woche bei Lidl für 119 Euro. Die unterbieten sich da irgendwie immer.
Das Problem ist, sie sollten noch einen Filzstift dazu verkaufen, weil nämlich Sony und andere Firmen sind auf die Idee gekommen, dass irgendwie CDs kopieren ja irgendwie blöd ist und die jetzt geschützt werden müssen gegen das Kopieren. Das Problem ist, es ist nicht wirklich ein Kopierschutz, weil Kopieren lassen sie sich nach wie vor wunderbar, aber sie lassen sich leider nicht auf jedem CD-Player abspielen. Nämlich insbesondere nicht auf solchen, die so kombinierte MP3 und DVD-Player sind, weil die ein CD-ROM-Laufwerk drin haben. Und da soll diese Sperre genau gelten. Es gibt in Amerika, in den USA gibt es einen Digital Copyright Millennium Act. Das ist also eine sehr scharfe, sehr strenge Gesetzgebung gegen die, gegen Urheberrechtsverstöße. Und da sind auch Hilfsmittel unter Strafe gestellt, die die Kopierschutz-Sachen oder irgendwelche Mechanismen umgehen. Das heißt, in Amerika müssten jetzt genau genommen Felsstifte verboten werden und Klebezettel und Klebebänder und so weiter. Weil damit kann man nämlich auch wunderbar diesen Kopierschutz umgehen. Das sind diversen Zeitschriften auch beschrieben worden. Da ist auch ein Link von unserer Seite dabei. Die Nachrichtenagentur Reuters müsste auch verklagt werden, weil die haben nämlich ausführlich darüber berichtet, über die Agenturen, wie das geht.
Na ja, wenn jetzt schon Nachrichtenagenturen verklagt werden dürfen, dass sie nicht zitieren dürfen, wer irgendwas über den Kanzler gesagt hat. Also das ist ja schon, das war ja mit den getönten Haaren. Hast du das mitgekriegt? Also die DDP, ich glaube die DDP, wahrscheinlich gibt es DDP gar nicht mehr, und ich rede nur davon, aber irgendeine Nachrichtenagentur war es, die hat eine Image-Beraterin zitiert und diese Image-Beraterin hat gesagt, der Kanzler solle aufhören, sich die Haare zu tönen. Daraufhin hat der Kanzler die Nachrichtenagentur verklagt, dass diese Nachrichtenagentur das Zitat nicht mehr bringen darf.
Unglaublich.
Das ist total, ich meine, hat ja nicht irgendetwas Besseres zu tun.
Genau, denn unser Freund Kim Schnitz ist ja wieder jetzt auf Bewehrung draußen, und er hat auch nicht weiter irgendwie, hat sich jetzt auch nicht zurückgehalten und er will auf jeden Fall im Jahr 2005 mit einem Flugzeugträger wiederkommen.
Ja und er mit einem Flugzeugträger.
Ja und die Strafe war irgendwie, was war das, 100.000 Euro oder so? Und abgezockt hat er irgendwie über eine Million.
1, 1 Millionen, 1, 2 Millionen. Ist denn auch so bescheuert, dass wenn jemand sagt, also wir bringen jetzt Let's Buy It, kommen wieder auf die Füße, dass er ein Aktien davon kaufen geht.
Na ja, ich meine er hat offensichtlich ein paar Dinge verstanden. Ja, obwohl man das ja nicht so sagen darf, aber er hat kapiert, dass wie es läuft.
Chaosradio 72 auf Fritz, immer noch. Frank war noch nicht fertig, es tut mir leid. Ich wollte dich nicht in deinem Fnuss unterbrechen.
Wir hatten am 25. Mai jetzt eine Anhörung zur Telekommunikationsüberwachung und da ging es um schwarze Kisten. Das ist nicht so eine lapse Bezeichnung, sondern es ist tatsächlich so der Sprachgebrauch da wohl. Es geht also um schwarze Kisten, also sprich irgendwelche Abhörgeräte, die irgendwie Voodoo machen, wo keiner so genau weiß, wie sie funktionieren, was sie tun, was damit passiert. Und die sollen bei den Internet-Providern eingebaut werden, um nämlich den Auslandsverkehr abzuhören. So, es gab ein bisschen Unklarheit darüber, wie irgendwie diese Änderungen gemacht werden sollen. Das heißt, was ins Gesetz geschrieben werden muss, zu was die Provider verpflichtet werden sollen, was die Dienste erwarten, was die Provider können und was natürlich auch die Politik dann noch durchgehen lassen will und was nicht. Das bleibt also nach wie vor spannend. Bei Counter-Strike irgendwie gab es eine Entscheidung nach dem Desaster in Erfurt. Man hat sich die Bundesprüfstelle ja nicht dazu durchringen können, das Spiel auf den Index zu setzen. Mit einer Begründung, naja, es ist halt auch ein taktisches Spiel und die Spieler können sich untereinander austauschen. Man kann also kooperativ spielen und das wiegt irgendwie diesem Blutspritz ein bisschen entgegen. Es gab aber sofort auch Proteste.
Von Kanzler interessant, das ist natürlich eine Frechheit, dass der also wirklich, nur weil er Kanzler ist, anfängt, die Entscheidung irgendeiner unabhängigen Institutionen anzuzweifeln. Also es ist ein bester Kohlmann hier irgendwie. Ich bin hier der König, ich darf.
Und dann hatten wir eine Abmahnwelle gegen Webseitenbetreiber, gegen Webmaster, weil sie ein Impressum vergessen haben. Das heißt, nach dem Tele-Dienstgesetz, mit dem Mediendienst, ist es vorgeschrieben, dass es eine Kennzeichnung ist, eine Anbieterkennzeichnung, und die muss sehr korrekt sein. Und da gab es irgendwie eine Abmahnwelle, ähnlich bei dieser Explorer-Geschichte, was auch so eine Serienabmahnung war, wo sich Anwälte, Atmahnanwälte, eine goldene Nase verdienen wollten. Wir hatten Einschränkungen des Datenschutzes an Schulen. Das heißt, auch bei Schülern, die über 18 sind, dürfen oder sollen die Eltern in Zukunft auch Auskunft kriegen über das, was in der Schule los ist. Das war bisher nicht so. Wenn jemand 18 war, dann kann er seine Entschuldigung selber schreiben und ist einfach für das auch selbst verantwortlich.
Finden wir das gut oder schlecht, dass das jetzt härter gestaltet wird?
Also ich meine, es gibt eine Schule auch in Deutschland, die zwar nicht öffentlich ist, eine private Schule, aber da werden Urin-Tests gemacht bei den Schülern.
Also da hört es aber dann auf.
Ich finde, es hört schon ein bisschen früher auf, aber okay, also es ist einfach so eine Sache, die muss man im Auge behalten, das ist das, was da passiert. Ja, das Telekommunikationsgesetz soll auch so geändert werden, dass bei Prepaid-Karten, bei Mobilfunk-Karten, also bei Sachen, die erstmal nicht persönlich gebunden sind, die sollen in Zukunft persönlich gebunden werden. Zum Beispiel durch die Angabe der Personalausweisnummer. Also das einfache Ansagen von der Adresse oder Aufschreibung reicht nicht aus, sondern das muss wirklich direkt personalisiert werden. Das hat einfach den Grund, dass die Bedarfsträger natürlich irgendwie ja wirklich auch wissen wollen, wer mit so einer Nummer telefoniert. Also wenn sie jetzt eine Nummer haben, dann wollen sie schon ziemlich genau wissen, wer dahinter steckt und nicht nur so ungefähr.
Ja, weil sie wollen natürlich auch ihre Kunden upgraden vom Prepaid-Produkt hin zu einem Festvertrag. Und dann ist es natürlich gut, wenn man die dann irgendwann mal anschreiben kann und denen sagen kann, hier wollte er nicht.
Das ist ja eine Sache, die die Industrie sich dann wünscht, bzw. die Mobilfunkunternehmen. Das ist jetzt eine Sache, die vom Gesetzgeber kommt. Und wo natürlich die Mobilfunkunternehmen schon Interesse dran haben, könnten die sagen, ja prima, finden wir gut. Aber es ist natürlich auch ziemlich viel Arbeit, sowas hineinzusammeln. Und sowas senkt natürlich auch wieder die Zahlen, weil sie haben jetzt einfach ein gewisses Klientel, behaupte ich mal, die auch einfach genau deswegen so eine Prepaid-Karte hat, weil sie eigentlich einigermaßen anonym sind. Oder zumindest ohne Vertrag, ohne Daten dalassen und dem ganzen Quatsch sind.
Wenn freust du rund um Cottbus, dann 103, 2.
22.31 Uhr.
Tritt Kurzinfo.
Heute Nacht 12 bis 8 Grad für Einzeltschauermorgens, dann heiter bis wolkig, gebietsweise vereinzelt Regen. Das ist, wenn Meteorologen ausschließen wollen, dass es hinterher heißt, hey, ihr habt gesagt, es regnet nicht. Also morgen wird's regnen, wo, das weiß noch keiner, aber die Temperaturen, die wissen wir, 21 Grad maximal und jetzt die Meldung mit Kerstin Topp.
Bei Tests im Mecklenburg-Vorpommern sind mit Nitrophäen belastete Eier und Geflügelfleisch gefunden worden. Landwirtschaftsminister Backhaus teilte mit, die Werte erreichten zum Teil das 18-fache des Erlaubten. Er geht davon aus, dass mehrere 10.000 Legehennen getötet werden müssen. Der Tarifkonflikt in der Druckindustrie ist beigelegt. Vertreter der Arbeitgeber und der Gewerkschaften verständigten sich auf eine Erhöhung der Einkommen um 3, 4 Prozent, rückwirkend zum 1. Mai. Unterdessen haben die Arbeitgeber des Baugewerbes in der letzten Schlichtungsrunde erstmals ein Angebot vorgelegt. Es liegt unter 2 Prozent. Die Gewerkschaft lehnte das ab. Die Friedenspflicht endet um Mitternacht. Das Finanzloch im brandenburgischen Haushalt ist deutlich größer als bisher erwartet. Insgesamt kommen 350 Millionen Euro mehr Belastung auf das Land zu, sagte Finanzministerin Ziegler. Allein die Steuerausfälle betrügen nach jüngsten Schätzungen im laufenden Jahr bis zu 244 Millionen Euro. Großbritanniens Außenminister Straw hat sich optimistisch geäußert, dass ein Krieg zwischen Indien und Pakistan vermieden werden kann. Straw sagte in Neu-Deli, die Lage sei zwar gefährlich, es gäbe aber noch Raum für eine politische Lösung. Im Osten Afghanistans haben die internationalen Truppen eine neue Militäraktion gegen Taliban-Kämpfer begonnen. Nach Angaben eines britischen Militärsprechers wurden rund 300 Marineinfanteristen in die Nähe der pakistanischen Grenze verlegt. Und zum Sport nach zehn Etappen im rosa Trikot hat Telekom-Profi Jens Heppner die Führung im Giro d'Italia abgegeben. Neuer Spitzenreiter ist der Australier Cadel Evans. Die Verkehrsmeldungen AC in Autobahn 3, Potztam, Schönefelder Kreuz. Zwischen Raststätte Michendorf und Potztam Süd ist wegen eines Unfalls der linke Fahrstreifen blockiert. Autobahn 3, Potztam, Schönefelder Kreuz, ebenfalls auf der 10 zwischen Raststätte Michendorf und Drebitz-Nutetal ist die Fahrbahn wegen Bauarbeiten auf einen Fahrstreifen verengt. A9, Potztam, Halle Leipzig zwischen Beelitz und Brück ist wegen eines Unfalls der rechte Fahrstreifen gesperrt. Stadtverkehr Berlin A111, Berlin Charlottenburg Autobahn 3, Oranienburg zwischen Kurt Schumacher Damm und Tunnel, Flughafen Tegel, derzeit ein Kilometer Stau und A100 Wilmersdorf-Lichtenberg im Ortskern Briz ist wegen Bauarbeiten der rechte Fahrstreifen gesperrt.
Fritz präsentationiert, holt, zeigt und bringt euch ein extra-absolut spezielles Samstag Zusatzkonzert. Die Toten Hosen. Live in der Wuhlheide.
Und zwar mit in extra-absolut spezielles Samstags Zusatzkonzert, weil das am Tag vorher ist ja schon ausverkauft. Die Toten Hosen.
Das Zusatzkonzert. Samstag, 29. Juni, ab 19 Uhr in der Wohlheide Berlin Köpenegg.
Chaosradio 72 ist es hier. Das wär's. 72 at chaosradio.ccc.de ist die E-Mail-Adresse nur für diese Sendung. Allgemeine Anfragen könnt ihr natürlich weiter, entweder chaosradio.fritz.de oder... Es gibt jetzt gar keine allgemeine Chaosradio-Adresse mehr bei euch in Frankreich.
Schon, aber wie war die bisher?
Ich hab immer alles Tim geforwarded. Nee, Chaosradio at Fritz.de. Also im Zweifelsfall Chaosradio at Fritz.de. Wenn ihr tatsächlich Anfragen explizit zu dieser Sendung habt, dann schickt sie an 72 at Chaosradio.ccc.de. Kommen wir doch mal zu unserem Thema heute Abend.
Musik kommt von Ellen.
Natürlich.
Wollten wir nochmal erwähnen.
Wer wollten wir nochmal erwähnen? Musik kommt von Ellen.
Von Ellen.
Richtig. Und jetzt Sarah nochmal.
Sehr gut.
Können wir jetzt mal mit dem Thema anfangen bitte?
Also ich fang mal an damit einfach. Und zwar, ich glaub, unser erster Punkt sind eigentlich sowas wie Happy Digits. Oder wie war da der Ausdruck? Happy Volksverarschung oder Pupsie Punkte?
Pupsie Punkte. Das ist Dietmar Wischmeier sagt das ja.
Also ich mein eigentlich geht's ja weiter. Also wir werden uns doch mal ein bisschen mit Electronic Privacy beschäftigen. Oder im Deutschen heißt es so schön Datenschutz, aber ist so ein bisschen abgestaubt.
Eigentlich ist blöd, weil wir wollen nicht die Daten schützen, sondern wir wollen die Leute schützen.
Also wir wollen die Privatsphäre erhalten. Naja und da ist vielleicht auch noch, da du jetzt mit den Nachrichten gerade aufgehört hast, mal komm ich nochmal mit einer Nachrichten, nämlich mit einer Veranstaltung, die nächste Woche stattfindet. Am 7. und 8. Juni, das ist eine Konferenz zum Thema Privacy unter www.safeprivacy.org kann man da die Veranstaltungshinweise finden. Und das sind eigentlich ganz interessante Workshops zum Thema. Auch tolle geladene Gäste, Simon Davis, Privacy International, Professoren, die sich hier sehr einsetzen in Deutschland. Also ist eine ganz spannende Geschichte und da trifft sich so die ganze Gemeinde zu dem Thema, was wir heute Abend haben.
Was sind denn Bonusprogramme?
Ja, also Bonusprogramme oder Loyalitätsprogramme, wie sie auch häufig genannt werden, sind Programme, wo Kunden teilnehmen können über Karten, also über Kundenkarten und wo sie im Prinzip dann Punkte sammeln. Und diese Punkte, wenn sie genügend gesammelt haben, dann können sie sich dafür eine Prämie einlösen. Also ich glaube, jeder kennt zum Beispiel dieses Lufthansa Miles und Moore Programm. Das ist so ein typisches Bonusprogramm, auch eines der ältesten in Deutschland, wenn nicht das älteste eigentlich. Mittlerweile hat das 3, 4 Millionen Kunden und da gehen einfach die Leute hin. Wenn sie fliegen, sie kaufen für 600 Mark oder 600 Euro im Flug. Und dann kriegen sie entsprechend irgendwie 1000 Meilen von Inlandsflug. Und nach 30 Inlandsflügen hat man dann so einen Gratisflug sich zusammengesammelt. Das ist eigentlich die Idee von dem Bonusprogramm. Und die Uridee ist ja dann eigentlich auch, dass dann die Firma den Flug zahlt und man hinterher dann privat in den Urlaub umsonst fliegt.
Zum Beispiel mit dem Guthaben kann man dann kostengünstig die gespielten zum Rammel-Weekend nach Paris entführen, wie das Dietmar Wischmeier in der letzten City sehr schön geschrieben hat.
Na das wird doch mal Rattenwohl dann, nicht?
Ja, wenn man vor allen Dingen bis nach Paris kommt. Denn ich hab mir den Spaß erlaubt, mal bei dem Happy-Digits-Programm von der Telekom nachzurechnen, was man denn jetzt eigentlich für, wenn man wirklich fleißig ist und sammelt und wirklich so 50 Euro im Monat Gesprächsbrut haben hat, dann braucht man 70 Jahre, um sich ein netteres Hightech-Gerät zusammenzusammeln.
Also was bezeichnest du jetzt als netteres Hightech-Gerät?
Nee, nee, nee, das ist schon DVD-Player. Also das ist schon okay, aber... 70 Jahre. Also ich weiß nicht, ob es dann noch DVD-Player gibt, aber...
Wobei, die verfallen ja auch, ne?
Ah ja, das stimmt, das hab ich ganz vergessen. Nach drei Jahren sind die ja auch schon wieder verfallen.
Das ist der letzte Betruch.
Also ich fand am besten das Wellness-Wochenende apropos Paris. Die bieten da ein Wellness-Wochenende in Potsdam an und da muss man 131, 3 Jahre für Punkte sammeln.
Für 50 Euro im Monat. Das ist ja richtig bei Payback, da gibt es eine Kaffeemaschine, bei ich glaube 4000 Punkten oder so.
Wie viele Jahre brauchst du dafür?
Naja, als Familie oder so schon lange. Keine Ahnung, gibt es eine Karte, also so einzeln nie benutzt.
Es ist auf jeden Fall wohl unterschiedlich, denn bei einigen Firmen ist halt ein Punkt nur ein Cent wert und bei Lufthansa zum Beispiel, also bei den Airlines, ist es bis zu 9 Cent wert. Also die sind völlig unterschiedlich viel wert und dementsprechend kriegt man auch schneller oder weniger schnell eine Prämie.
Ich bin schon mal da.
Ich bin schon mal da. Ich bin schon mal da. Ich bin schon mal da. Ich bin schon mal da. Ich bin schon mal da. Ich bin schon mal da. Ich bin schon mal da. Ich bin schon mal da. Ich glaube, dass man dem Kunden gegenüber fair bleibt und wenn man wirklich weiß, was mit den Daten passiert, die da gesammelt werden, ich glaube, da kommen wir ja gleich noch zu, oder das überhaupt, warum überhaupt Bonusprogramme eingeführt werden. Das ist eben wichtig für die bewusste Entscheidung des Kunden, sich für so ein Programm zu entscheiden. Und ich meine, man fragt sich ja bei der Bahn, warum eigentlich? Ich hab doch schon eine Karte. Also was wollen die eigentlich?
Vor allem gibt es auch nicht mal eine vernünftige Prämie bei der Bahn. Gibt es da irgendwie Freifahrten, einen Kaffee oder?
Also man kann irgendwie in die DB Lounge gehen und wenn man mal in Frankfurt ist...
Also ich hab eine Bahnkarte, damit ich billiger reisen kann. Und damit kann ich doch in die DB Lounge gehen. Also zumindest habe ich da mit in Frankfurt am Main in der DB Lounge gesessen. Und die haben gesagt, ja, nee, dann dürfen sie ja rein, als ich das hochgehalten habe.
Was ist denn die DB Lounge?
Das ist einfach so ein Wartebereich, der irgendwie ein bisschen nettere Stühle hat und wo du dir einen Pilz kaufen kannst oder so. Und die Leute dich einfach in Ruhe lassen und nicht immer irgendwelche Leute ankommen und so Sachen sagen wie, hey, hast du mal eine Marke?
Also ich meine, man kriegt im Prinzip nicht viel mehr, als wenn man eine Bahncard schon hat. Man kriegt wohl einen Sitzplatz reserviert, aber man kriegt ja eigentlich sowieso immer einen Sitzplatz. Jaja, eben. Man bekommt angeblich mal irgendwann einen Parkplatz, aber ich habe da mal bei der Hotline angerufen und die wissen auch noch nicht, ob es da je Parkplätze gibt. Da steht zwar schnell in Froschüren, an den Hauptbahnhöfen angeblich. Wo denn? Wo denn?
Ja, das liegt in Berlin. Ja, das liegt in Berlin. Ja, das liegt in Berlin.
Also auf jeden Fall, ich mein gut, einige sind besser, einige sind schlechter. Wir wollen jetzt nicht so sehr ins Eingemachte gehen. Aber Tatsache ist jedenfalls, also was die eigentlich wollen, ist die wollen die Aussage, die wollen die Bahnencard mit der Information, wer der Kunde ist, wollen die linken mit dem Mobilitätsverhalten. Genau den Link können die bisher mit der Bahnencard nicht machen. Stimmt.
Ja, außer wenn du telefonisch bestellst. Nee, selbst dann nicht. Also dann können sie es auch nicht mit der Bahnencard. Ja doch schon.
Ja nur dann aber. Ich gehe ja immer zu diesen wunderbaren Automaten, wo ich dann stundenlang stehe, um hinterher festzustellen, dass sie meine Zahlungsmittel nicht akzeptieren.
Wieso, was willst du da immer reintun?
Und zum Schluss fragen sie mich auch noch, ob ich Punkte haben will, dann bin ich richtig sauer.
Ja gut, also aber im Prinzip, also geht es ja darum, dass sie nun eigentlich herausfinden wollen, welche Kunden fahren wann, wohin, wie oft. Und wenn sie dann zum Beispiel feststellen, auch da fährt immer einer nach Berlin, dann können sie ihm hinterher eben auch Werbung schicken, zu Berliner Hotels oder zu Services in Berlin oder was weiß ich.
Aber was ist denn mit der Telekom, also ich meine, sie sammelt ja auch oder sie bietet an, Punkte zu sammeln mit den Kunden und die Telekom weiß ja, wohin die Leute telefonieren. Was haben die denn? Also da geht es vielleicht nur darum, einfach um Kunden zu binden, dass die Leute da bleiben, dass sie denken, toll, Sammelwut zu befriedigen.
Wahrscheinlich weil es alle machen. Ist eben so oder?
Schön wärs, schön wärs. Also ich bin da, ich hab mir mal die Mühe gemacht, mal ein bisschen geguckt und hab festgestellt, also die Telekom hat ja ein Problem, die wissen ja nur, dass die, wo die Leute hin telefonieren. Aber die wissen nichts anderes über den Kunden und damit haben die wohl ein Problem. Also gehen die hin und wenn man dann bei den Happy Digits mal ins Detail einsteigt, sieht man dann nicht unter Partnerfirmen wohlgemerkt, sondern unter dem Thema Datenschutz. Ja, also da werden auch noch Daten dann irgendwann gepult und zwar über irgendeine Firma, die heißt da ganz unscheinbar Cup Customer Advantage Program GmbH. Und dann stellt man fest, das ist ein Joint Venture mit CarShut Quelle.
Und da haben wir sie doch, oder? Wobei das ja eigentlich auch vollkommen egal ist, weil die Telekom ja noch nicht mehr in der Lage ist, ihre Abrechnungsdaten ordentlich zu verarbeiten. Von daher können sie gerne auch noch meine anderen Daten haben. Die küffen mir voll. Ich schenke denen mein Profil. Mal gucken, was die da was machen. Wahrscheinlich bin ich dann irgendwie eine 77-jährige bulgarische Wäscherin oder sowas.
Das Problem ist, dass sie es einfach eins zu eins durchgeben. Und die beiden Firmen, die sind glaube ich ganz gut mittlerweile, sind sowas.
Quelle CarShut? Ja sicher. Wovon sollen sie sonst halt schmitt bezahlen? Chaosradio 72, heute ein bisschen basslastig und punktesammelnd. Ja, also im Studio, wenn keiner was sagt, dann sag ich eben was, das hab ich gelernt bzw. nicht mal das hab ich gelernt. Im Studio, also das, was hier gerade redet, heißt Holger Klein. Außerdem noch Sarah und Frank und Sarah erzählt gerade über Rabattkartensysteme. Ich weiß noch, bei Feinkorps Schneider in Weilerswies, wo ich aufgewachsen bin, da gab es immer Rabattmarken. Und dann hast du die in ein Rabattmarkenheft geklebt und irgendwann bist du dann mit dem Rabattmarkenheft voll zu Feinkorps Schneider gegangen und ich weiß nicht mehr im geringsten, was es dafür gab, aber es muss irgendwas Nettes gewesen sein.
Das war bestimmt für die Knusperpunkte, das waren ja 20 Fußballerbilder. Das Album hat in 19, 80 Mark gekostet.
Das war schon Naturalien und so. Du konntest doch mal bei Feinkorps Schneider für so und so viel Mark einkaufen können.
Wir hatten hier auch noch das Rabattgesetz. Die konnten das gar nicht beliebig machen, sondern durften nur maximal 3% oder so.
Drei Prozent haben sich die Bonusprogramme nie durchgesetzt in Deutschland. Das gab es quasi nicht, weil das in Amerika und Holland immer schon Usus war. Ja, also Cashtat hat ja da auch so eine ganz tolle Rabattkarte. Das machen auch relativ viele Leute.
Diese Kundenkarte, mit der du auch als Kreditkarte benutzen kannst, ist das gleichzeitig.
Genau, aber da hat es dann in sich, wenn man sich hier mal so eine Solitär-Card, also ich finde den Namen Solitär-Card schon so doof, ich komme solitär-Card, das hört sich so nach Solokarte an.
Ja, wie auch immer, guck dich mal um, wie Sachen mittlerweile heißen, also es geht ja eh gar nicht mehr.
Ich habe mir Hapily hier diesen Ausdruck geben lassen, um mich bei der Solitär-Card anzumelden, und natürlich mit Zahlungsfunktion, und da wollen die also von mir wissen, also nicht nur also Name und Anschrift und Telefon und all diese Dinge, das ist ja sowieso schon ganz normal und das ist klar, ob das so klar ist. Aber dann gehen die also hin und wollen also von mir den Geburtsort und ob ich ledig verheiratet geschieden bin, was ich für eine Staatsangehörigkeit habe, ob ich zur Miete wohne, ob ich eine eigene Wohnung habe, wollen die wissen.
Das Einkommen. Wie oft haben sie Sex die Woche?
Mit der Wohnung kriegst du dann hinterher Post von der Noris Bank.
Finanzieren sie doch ihr Haus.
Ja genau, genau.
Sie wollen den Namen vom Partner haben, Sie wollen wissen, wo der arbeitet, in welcher Branche. Sie wollen die Telefonnummer haben. Ja hier genau. Also berufliche Angaben Ihres Ehepartners. Beruf, Position, Branche, Arbeitgeber, Telefon, ob er angestellt oder selbstständig ist und seit wann.
Das ist klasse. Und das Schlimme ist, Sie behaupten, es wäre dann natürlich auch um die Kreditwürdigkeit. Das heißt also, das ist ja eine Karte, wo ich dann diese Bezahlfunktion auch mit hab. Und Sie brauchen das für die Schufa. Das ist ja Auskunftsteil, die also sagt, ob jemand kreditwürdig ist oder nicht. Beziehungsweise ob er schon irgendwelche offenen Sachen irgendwo hat. Aber die Schufa brauchen natürlich diese Angaben gar nicht.
Aber was brauchen die denn? Die brauchen Namen und Geburtsdatum, damit können die dich dann nicht in die Infizierung schüren.
Noch ein letzter Wohnanschrift, glaube ich, oder so was, wenn man umgezogen ist.
Genau, also die brauchen eigentlich nur polizeiliche Anschrifte, diese Geschichte. Name und Geburtsdatum. Aber das ist doch interessant. Oder so hinten auf diesem Solidärantrag steht nämlich auch was von Schufan. Da denkt man dann wirklich so... Also ich bin ja ins KDB gegangen und hab dann da mit dieser Kundenberaterin gesprochen und hab gesagt, ich will so eine Karte haben und hab die gefragt. Ich sag, ich will das eigentlich nicht alles ausfüllen. Das kommt mir so komisch vor. So und dann hat sie gesagt, ja, das käme ja, wüsste sie auch nicht so genau. Und die sah auch so aus, als wäre es plötzlich auch komisch vorgegeben. Und dann hat sie also noch bei zwei, drei Stellen angerufen im Haus, bei der Bearbeitung hier und die konnten das alles nicht sagen. Und dann kam so in etwa die Aussage zurück, ja, also sie müssen das schon ausfüllen, weil sonst wissen wir nicht, was passiert. Also dann kriegen sie die Karte wahrscheinlich.
Dann wäre doch immer ein prima Spaß, alle, die jetzt hier zuhören, in Karstadt zu schicken und zu sagen, wir hätten gerne Kundenkarten. Aber sagen sie mal, warum wollen sie denn diese ganzen Angaben von mir? Können wir das noch mal irgendwie klären?
Genau, Leute.
Und dann mal irgendwie in Karstadt einen halben Tag lahmlegen?
Genau, also Leute, geht nicht zu Karstadt und fragt dort nicht nach Karstadt.
Nein, macht das nicht, obwohl es doch keine Aufruf zu einer, also wir fordern die nicht zu einer Straftataufentwicklung.
Holt euch doch alle diese Kraten, das ist toll. Das hat die Tatze übrigens auch gemacht.
Vorhin müssen wir noch eins klären. Gibt es groben Unfug eigentlich noch als ordnungswidrig?
Nee, aber die Tatze hat doch so eine Aktion gemacht, dass sie für andere Zeitungen Abos eingeworben haben. Das ist aufgrund des schlechten Zeitungsmarktes. Sie haben nicht nur für sich Abos angeworben und haben gesagt, Leute, holt euch doch zum Beispiel bei der Frankfurter Allgemeinen oder beim Tagesspiegel auch ein Abo. Sie haben halt nicht entweder Dankesbriefe gekriegt, sondern irgendwie Abmahnungen und Anrufe von bösen Rechtsanwälten.
Also, liebe Höhrende, geht nicht zu Karstadt. Fragt bei Karstadt nicht nach einer dieser Kundenkarten. Und wenn ihr bei Karstadt nicht nach einer dieser Kundenkarten gefragt habt, was ihr ja gar nicht könnt, weil ihr nicht hingegangen seid, dann setzt auch bitte nicht diese Abteilung in Marsch, euch zu erklären, was denn mit diesen Daten alles passiert. Also macht das bitte nicht. Danke. Ende der Durchsage, wir können weitermachen. Ach, Musik, Musik. Hallöchen, hier ist Chaosradio 72 auf Fritz. Wir waren gerade bei Carstadt Kundenkarten. Hast du, Sarah, hast du denn rausgefunden, jetzt was Carstadt mit den Daten macht, die Carstadt alle haben will, ohne sie haben zu müssen?
Na ja, also ich meine, natürlich kann einem die Kundenbetreuerin da nichts sagen, was die mit den Daten machen. Und ich bin auch mir nicht ganz sicher, ob, also es herrscht ja in Deutschland gesetzlich so ein Prinzip der Datensparsamkeit. Das heißt, dass man bei einem Vertragsabschluss oder wie auch immer, also dass man eigentlich nicht mehr Daten abfragen darf, als man für den Zweck braucht.
Ach, das heißt, es könnte sogar sein, dass Karstadt sich da gesetzwidrig verhält?
Na ja. Also das will ich jetzt auch nicht so. Das will ich jetzt. Ich bin keine Juristin, insofern will ich das nicht sagen.
Habt auch noch nicht einen Juristen gefragt oder so. Das wäre wirklich interessant.
Das sollten wir eigentlich machen. Aber unser Jurist, den wir heute Abend einschalten wollten, hat uns leider abgesucht.
Sind Sie ihm auf die Schliche gekommen?
Irgendwann, in gewisser Weise natürlich so, dass die Leute, dass ein gewissen Ziel von solchen Firmen ist ja, dass man diese Daten benutzt, um den Kunden besser kennenzulernen und um ihm auf Basis dieser, dieses besser kennenlernen, dieses Wissen über den Kunden dann persönliche Angebote machen kann. Ja gut, also sagen wir mal so, man muss das 40 Prozent der Deutschen sagen, dass sie das ganz okay finden, dass sie das eine gute Sache finden. 60 Prozent sagen, dass sie das ziemlich doof finden.
Ja, aber ich glaube, dass diese 40 Prozent, die gehen dann davon aus, dass sie dann weniger Werbung im Briefkasten haben hinterher, weil ja nur noch das kommt, was sie wirklich haben wollen. Aber das ist doch Illusor. Die haben doch dreimal so viel und dann nur noch für Opel.
Richtig. Ja, man muss auch richtig aufpassen bei diesen Befragungen, weil man halt irgendwie diese Prozentzahlen, die da rauskommen, auch immer zu hinterfragen sind. Das, was die Leute jetzt wirklich denken, weiß man auch nicht so hundertprozentig. Naja, jedenfalls, also um das um das nochmal so ein bisschen zu auszubreiten. Also es geht eigentlich, es gibt da verschiedene Dinge, die die Firmen machen wollen. Da sind zirkulieren so Begriffe wie Upselling oder Cross Selling oder Preisdifferenzierung. Also Upselling, was ist das? Das bedeutet eigentlich, dass also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel Informationen haben über das Reiseverhalten von den Leuten, also die fliegen immer nach Spanien, dann kann ich eben, dann gehe ich eben hin und verkaufe ihnen dann auch Hotels in Spanien oder Autovermietungen in Spanien. Also ich bleibe eigentlich so in meiner Produktkategorie.
Oder ich frage, wollen sie nicht auch einfach mal nach New York fliegen zum Beispiel? Also ich weiß, die fliegen schon mal, ich weiß zwar nicht, was die sonst machen, aber sie fliegen, also Hotels, Flüge, Mietwagen und so.
Das ist das, was das macht, American Express macht das ja permanent, also mit jeder Rechnung hast du irgendwie noch ein Beiblatt, wo dann drauf steht, ja also wenn du irgendwie viel essen gegangen bist, kriegst du von American Express auf der Rechnung, freundlicherweise kündigen die das aber auch an, also die sagen vorher, sie kriegen dann, wenn sie wollen und so, ansonsten verwerten wir die Daten intern.
So, aber das ist genau der Punkt, also American Express hat schon vor Jahren gesagt, dass sie mit ihren Kundeninformationen mehr Geld verdienen, als mit ihrem Kreditskartengeschäft.
Ja natürlich, bei den Provisionen, die die Geschäfte für Amex zu zahlen haben, nehmen die die alle nicht an.
Ja, so kann man.
Das ist echt so, da sind die höchsten Provisionen drauf, wenn die Geschäftsleute sagen, American Express, geh mir weg.
Ja vor allen Dingen, ich meine, die kriegen halt relativ viel Geld für die Werbung, wie du gerade beschrieben hast, weil sie es eben genau so detailliert runterbrechen, wem sie dann was schicken, weil du kriegst ja einen ganz anderen Brief als dein Nachbar oder ich oder so.
Was ist Cross Selling?
Also Cross Selling bedeutet das Ausschöpfen des Kundenpotenzials durch Verkäufe verschiedener Produktkategorien. Die Betriebswirtschaft hat ja immer so ihre tollen Definitionen. Also im Prinzip bedeutet das oder man hat rausgefunden, wenn Männer in den Supermarkt gehen und sie kaufen Windeln, dann kaufen sie immer Bier dazu. Doch, echt.
So ist es.
Ach komm, ich hab noch nie Bier gekauft, wenn ich Windeln geholt hab.
Ja du vielleicht nicht.
Also.
Ja, aber die Masse der Männer kaufen also immer Bier und Windeln zusammen.
Ja und alle Männer weigern sich, Achterpakete Toilettenpapier zu kaufen.
Ich muss aufpassen, weil wenn du das nächste Mal in den Supermarkt gehst und du kaufst, du bist an dem Punkt, wo du Windeln kaufst, wird dir Bier angeboten. Oder nee, besser wär ja noch, du gehst und kaufst Bier und es werden dir Windeln angeboten.
Das wär klasse, weil ich mich immer in Kontinents saufe. Wie gut ist die Marketing-Abscheidung?
Und es wird dann durch Analysen, also durch Statistiken praktisch rausgefunden, oder wie? Also ich kann es ja nur, also wenn ich sonst nichts über den Kunden weiß, kann ich ja nur anhand dem, was er bei mir einkauft oder betrifft es jetzt schon so Firmen im Verbund, so was wie Payback oder sowas.
Nee, also das man kann, gut, natürlich kann man diese Art Analysen nur machen, wenn man ein breiteres Produktspektrum abbildet. Also zum Beispiel, dass man überhaupt Bier und Windeln zusammen verkauft. Und da ist dein Hinweis schon ganz richtig. Also diese Punkte, Programme wie Payback, wo es eigentlich darum geht, den Warenkorb abzubilden, also möglichst viele verschiedene Parteien da drin zu haben, die können dann genau dieses Cross Selling auch machen. Also womit wir eigentlich bei dem Thema Payback sind. So ein bisschen.
Ja, dann beschäftigen wir uns mit Payback, nachdem wir haben sagen lassen, wie diese Sendung heißt. Ist. Chaosradio 72 um 23.00 Uhr und vier Minuten hier auf... Wir reden gleich über Payback und vorher noch ein bisschen Musik von LN und wo die auch live zu hören ist und nicht nur hier im Radio live, also live ist sie, sag mal hallo LN. Also sie ist wirklich live im Radio und sie wird auch auflegen und wo das sein wird, das werden wir im Anschluss an diese Sendung bzw. also in dieser Sendung noch im Anschluss an diese Sendung. Ich halte jetzt einfach mal meinen Maul und lasse die Platte laufen.
Und ich hab nie genug.
Chaosradio 72, unsere Pause ist vorbei. Wir haben auch unsere Probleme gelöst in der Zeit. Ja, so einfach kann das manchmal gehen. Wo war man stehen geblieben jetzt eigentlich hier?
Wir hatten uns gerade unterhalten über diese Cross-Selling-Geschichten, sprich also Stichwort Babynahrung und Bier werden zusammen gekauft. Wir haben uns unterhalten über den Wunsch von Firmen, den gesamten einen Einblick in den gesamten Barenkorb von Kunden zu halten. Also im Prinzip ja doch eine ganz aussagekräftige Geschichte. Wenn ich weiß, was du kaufst, dann weiß ich auch, wer du bist.
Ja sicher. Also gut, dann drängt sich natürlich die Frage auf, wie verhindere ich das? Okay, ich nehme keine von diesen komischen Karten, Sammelmarken und sonst irgendwie was. Also ich gehöre möglichst zu keinem Club, der von mir eine Unterschrift haben will und ein paar Daten haben will. Also vielleicht gerade mal zur Bank und zur Telekom.
Aber du benutzt halt die Privacy-Karten. Das ist ja echt ein sehr cooler Heck. Ja, deswegen werden wir jetzt auch gleich mal die Rena einschalten. Und zwar gibt es in Deutschland ein System, das heißt Payback. Das hat 17 Millionen Kunden und das ist eben eine Kundenkarte, wo man also in der Galeria Kaufhof und auch bei dir an der Tankstelle, bei 1000 Firmen, Realmarkt, genau, sehr wichtig für den Warenkorb auch. Man kann also überall, wo man hingeht, zeigt mir diese Karte vor, kriegt Punkte auf diese Karte und hat damit seinen Einkauf mit seinem Namen und registriert. Dafür gibt es Prämien und solche Geschichten.
Da gibt es erstmal Punkte für, das sind diese Payback-Punkte. Und für 1000 Punkte oder 4000 oder so was in der Größenordnung gibt es dann eine Prämie. Und Payback waren ja eigentlich so die ersten, die so ein Rabattsystem im großen Stil eingeführt haben hier in Deutschland, die auch sehr erfolgreich waren. Allerdings hat es auch einen Grund, warum die wirtschaftlich gesehen recht erfolgreich waren auch bisher. Sie haben viele Partnerunternehmen auch gefunden und das ist bei der Bevölkerung recht weit akzeptiert, weil die auch viel Werbeaufwand natürlich reingesteckt haben.
17 Millionen Kunden ist ja wirklich nicht zu unterschätzen.
Das ist enorm. 17 Millionen Leute, die sagen, wieso, ich habe da nichts zu verbergen.
Tatsache ist dann halt, dass nach dem Aufzeichnen dieser Transaktionen, werden dann den Kunden individualisierte Werbematerialien und solche Sachen geschickt und nur wie die halt im Prinzip auch ihren Kunden, ihre Kunden über den Tisch ziehen, wenn diese...
Na ja, das ist ein bisschen bösartig. Also ich meine, für die Kunden ist es natürlich nur von Vorteil, weil sie sammeln Punkte und sie können zielgruppengerechte Werbung erhalten. Also für den Kunden ist es ja eigentlich erstmal nicht so negativ unbedingt.
Ja, aber immerhin haben sie die Big Brother Award bekommen, ne? Also wobei... Du kannst mir das ja nicht erklären, also müssen wir jetzt Rena anrufen.
Genau, wir haben jetzt Rena am Telefon.
Haben wir schon, ja.
Und Rena erzählt uns jetzt mal, warum Payback den Big Brother Award bekommen hat und was der Big Brother Award ist.
Ja, hallo, schönen guten Abend. Rena Tangels aus Bielefeld. Erzähl ich natürlich gerne, denn Payback ist sozusagen unser Lieblingskunde in Sachen Big Brother Awards.
Wer ist denn wir? Sag doch noch mal, wo du eigentlich, was so dein Ding ist.
Wir ist das FöBoot e.V. in Bielefeld und FöBoot ist die Abkürzung für den unaussprechlichen Namen Verein zur Förderung des öffentlichen, bewegten und unbewegten Datenverkehrs.
Ich hätte eine Anmerkung. FöBoot schreibt man aber doch mit F und Verein nicht...
Richtig, Förderung, Förderung.
Förderung, nein, Entschuldigung, ja danke.
Ansonsten nicht mit Logik kommen bei diesem Namen. Das ist eine Parodie auf die damals üblichen Abkürzungen der Post, also das, was jetzt Telekom ist, als die noch für Telekommunikation zuständig waren.
Was hat es mit dem Big Brother Award auf sich?
Ja, der Big Brother Award ist ein Negativpreis, also so was wie der Oscar für Datenkraken, also ein Negativpreis für Firmen, Politiker, Institutionen, die die Privatsphäre von Menschen ganz besonders dauerhaft und heftig verletzen. Den verleiht eine Jury von diversen sehr kompetenten Menschen. Und der FöBoot ist Organisator dieser Veranstaltung, also von der großen Preisverleihung, die findet immer Ende Oktober statt. Und das hatten wir in Deutschland bereits zweimal. Und Payback war Hauptpreisträger im Jahr 2000.
Und wer sonst noch?
Oh, vom Jahr 2000 oder überhaupt?
Überhaupt. Also von euch, wenn es das nur zweimal gab, dann ist so viel gewesen.
Entschuldigung, wenn ich hier vorweggreife, einen besonderen Preis hat zum Beispiel der freie Web-Server Apache bekommen, weil er nämlich in der Standard-Einstellung einfach mal sämtliche Daten ins Log-File schreibt. Also das war zwar ein bisschen...
Ich muss dabei festhalten, die Standard-Einstellung hat diesen Preis bekommen, nicht der Apache-Webserver. Den benutzen wir selber übrigens auch.
Ja, richtig.
Ok, komm mal wieder.
Otto Schiehli hat das im letzten Jahr bekommen, das hat sich freundlich aufgedrängt und der Preisträger im Bereich Business und Finanzen vom Jahr 2001 ist auch ganz interessant, aber da kommen wir sicher später noch zu.
Tu mir das. Sag mal, gib mal einen Tipp wenigstens.
Informa.
Danke.
Ah, genau.
Kommen wir zu Payback zurück.
Warum habt ihr denn an Payback die Big Brother verliehen, die Award?
Also für Payback gab es jede Menge Gründe. Kundenkarten an sich sind schon etwas, was man sich sorgfältig angucken sollte. Payback war dann sicherlich auch der größte Player in diesem Bereich zu der Zeit. Und wir haben uns Payback dann mal genauer unter die Lupe genommen und haben jede Menge Sachen entdeckt, die wir zu beanstanden hatten. Und das geht los damit, dass da Daten gesammelt werden, also eine Unmenge persönlicher Daten, die zur Rabattgewährung und zur Abwicklung des Programms überhaupt nicht notwendig wären. Aber während Payback die ganze Zeit suggeriert, es geht um Punkte sammeln und Spaß haben und Geld sparen und so weiter und der eigentliche Geschäftszweck, nämlich, dass es natürlich darum geht, möglichst viele Daten von Kunden zu bekommen, was sie denn eigentlich so einkaufen über die Jahre hinweg, das wird dort nicht bekannt gegeben.
Das stimmt, zur Abwicklung, zur Abwicklung meines Rabattanspruches bräuchten die doch eigentlich überhaupt keine Daten von mir. Ich muss doch nur eine Karte haben, auf der diese Punkte gut geschrieben sind oder nicht?
Richtig, und sie brauchen, weil sie clevererweise diesen Rabatt erst nachträglich gewähren, brauchen sie dann deine Kontonummer, damit sie dir das überweisen können. Und du musst erst mal 1500 Punkte angesammelt haben, bevor du Geld zurückbekommst.
Oder einen Gegenstand oder was gibt es denn da als Premium?
Man kann auch Premiums nicht bestellen, aber sie haben zunächst damit angefangen, dass man einfach Geld zurückbekommt. Und zwar bekommt man zwischen 1 und 3 Prozent und 100 Punkte sind 1, 96 Mark.
Wie funktioniert dieses Payback-System genau? Ich weiß, da gibt es eine Plastikkarte, da ist ein Magnetstreifen drauf und ein Barcode und dann wird vor dem Bezahlvorgang eingescannt.
Du schiebst deine Waren auf das Bunchball im Real-Supermarkt zum Beispiel und dann legst du deine Karte gleich noch mit drauf und dann wird die auch einfach über den Scanner gezogen und dann werden dir die Punkte gut geschrieben.
Und die Daten von meinem Einkauf, also ein, zwei Mal Butter, drei Cola?
Ja, du hast damit auch zu sagen, dass du deinen Einkaufszettel an der Kasse hier abgegeben hast. Und damit ist zum ersten Mal für Real möglich, deinen Einkaufszettel mit deiner Person und deinen sonstigen Angaben zu verknüpfen. Das ging vorher nicht. Sie konnten zwar sehen, dass Leute, die Windeln kaufen, auch Bier kaufen. Hey, das konnten sie ja schon vorher sehen. Das ist uninteressant. Sie können das jetzt aber mit deiner Person verknüpfen.
Und welchen Vorteil bringen mir jetzt diese Leute, die will es? Es gibt viele Partnerunternehmen, das heißt also, dass nicht nur real drin ist, sondern auch eine Tankstellenkette, Optiker, einen Kaufhof.
Also, OBI-Baumarkt. Man kann also wirklich so quer durch den Garten einkaufen, was auch Sinn der Sache ist, weil man damit einen möglichst vollständigen Warenkorb bekommt. Und Payback-Strategie ist auch möglichst aus jedem Geschäftsbereich, also aus jeder Branche eigentlich nur eine Firma zu kaufen.
Sag mal, ihr Payback habt das statt doch jetzt auch vor Gericht oder ihr habt, da gab es auch so...
Das ist eine längere Geschichte.
Aber gib doch mal...
Kurz sie ab und erklär sie uns.
Genau, gib doch mal ein paar Tipps, weil das ist eigentlich ganz spannend.
Ich erklär mal kurz, welche Daten sie überhaupt noch erheben und warum wir das nicht toll finden. Also, da wird eben nicht nur Name, Adresse und Kontonummer wiegen wir noch, damit sie den Rabatt erstatten können, sondern da wird auch noch gefragt nach Telefonnummer, Mobiltelefonnummer, E-Mail-Adresse und wenn man an einem Preisserschreiben teilnehmen will, wird dann noch gefragt nach, leben sie alleine oder mit Partner, sind sie verheiratet, haben sie Kinder, Geburtsdaten der Kinder und monatliches Nettoeinkommen und wenn man das auch noch ausfüllt, dann bekommt man, hat man die Chance in einem Preisserschreiben einen Freiflug nach New York zu gewinnen, selbstverständlich mit der Lufthansa, denn die Lufthansa ist Hauptanteilseigner von dieser Firma, die in Hebek steht. Diese Firma wiederum hatte sich zu der Zeit, wo wir ihnen den Award vergeben haben, auch völlig unsichtbar gemacht und war weder im Impressum noch sonst irgendwo festzustellen und es war insgesamt eine sehr undurchsichtige Sache, was da eigentlich gemacht werden soll. Es wurde also den Kunden immer vorgespiegelt, es geht um Geld sparen und Spaß haben und was eigentlich mit den Daten alles gemacht werden kann. Das ist den meisten Leuten unklar.
Aber ist das denn legal? Also ich meine, wir haben ja schon gehört, dass eigentlich dieser Grundsatz der Datensparsamkeit gilt.
Das Problem ist, dass es gibt das, du kannst einen, entweder wird nach den gesetzlichen Regelungen vorgegangen oder aber du hast ein Einverständnis gegeben. Das Einverständnis wird nach deutschem Recht sehr hoch gewertet. Wenn du mit etwas einverstanden bist, dann kannst du dich vielleicht sogar in die Sklaverei verkaufen und wenn du an dieser Stelle unterschreibst, dass du einverstanden bist, dass deine Daten zur Werbemarktforschung und Marketing-Zwecken verwendet werden, dann ist das so.
Was macht Payback, wenn ich das durchstreiche? Das ist immer so ein Formtext.
Ja, dann dürfen sie die Daten dafür eigentlich nicht verwenden.
Würden sie mich trotzdem als Mitglied nehmen?
Im Antrag kannst du nichts durchstreichen. Wenn du das dort tust, wenn du sagst, ich bin nicht einverstanden, dann kam die Rückfrage vom Server, wollen sie den Vorgang wirklich abbrechen? Das heißt, du bist unmöglich gemacht, das anders zu tun. Dann wollte ich kurz darauf eingehen, ihr habt eben so ein paar mal scherzhaft gesagt, falsche Angaben machen oder ganz viel irgendwie ausfüllen, um die zu verwirren. Ich muss dazu sagen, das klappt nicht. Das finde ich etwas naiv. Guckt euch Google an, was aus einer Unmenge von Daten trotzdem an relevanten Sachen herausgefunden wird. Das ist erstaunlich. Und da sollte man auch die Leute, die aus vielen verschiedenen Datenbanken Daten zusammenbringen, nicht unterschätzen, dass sie unsinnige Angaben nicht ohne Probleme ausfiltern könnten. Also da sollte man ein bisschen vorsichtig sein. Und es gibt keine unwichtigen Daten. Also Leute denken ja, ist doch mir egal, wenn jemand weiß, welche Kaffeesorte oder O-Saft oder keine Ahnung, was ich da einkaufe. Einige sind sicher sogar noch stolz drauf, weil sie bestimmte Marken kaufen und ein bisschen ihre Identität auch damit darstellen können. Aber auch wenn diese Sachen heutzutage noch völlig unbedenklich und banal sind, können die in ein paar Jahren was ganz anderes bedeuten. Ich bring mal ein Beispiel. Wenn du vor fünf Jahren Rindfleisch eingekauft hast beim real in Sonderangebot, also besonders billig, aus zweifelhafter Quelle möglicherweise, dann wäre an diesen Daten heutzutage eine Krankenkasse durchaus interessiert. Dann würde sie dir nämlich nicht unbedingt ein Angebot für eine günstigere Versicherung machen. Das heißt, auch wenn Payback sagt, sie geben diese Daten nicht weiter, das mag ja alles gut gemeint sein, aber es kann trotzdem immer sein, dass später ganz andere Regeln aufkommen und dieser Datenbestand, wenn er erstmal vorhanden ist, dann weckt er Begehrlichkeiten. Da möchten viele ran, da möchten Ermittlungsbehörden dran. Die möchten zum Beispiel mal gucken, wer hat denn in letzter Zeit Puderzucker, einen Wecker bei Galeria Kaufhof, dann vielleicht noch Düngemittel bei OBI eingekauft und dann könnte schon mal eine selbstgepastete Bombe dabei rausgekommen sein.
Sabrina, wir müssen Nachrichten machen. Du bleibst bitte dran. Über euren Umgang mit Payback reden wir dann nach den Nachrichten.
Wenn Fritz in Frankfurt oder? Dann 101, 5.
Heute Nacht 12 bis 8 Grad vereinzelt Schauer, morgen dann heiter bis wolkig, gebietsweise vereinzelt Regen bis 21 Grad und die Meldungen mit Kersting Top.
Die Frist für die Schlichtung im Baugewerbe ist verlängert worden, das teilte der Vorsitzende der Schlichtungskommission Geißler mit. Ursprünglich wäre die Friedenspflicht um Mitternacht abgelaufen, die Arbeitgeber bieten bisher gut ein Prozent mehr Geld. Die IG BAU will 4, 5 Prozent. In der Druckindustrie haben sich die Tarifparteien einen Tag vor der Uhrabstimmung über einen Streik doch noch geeinigt. Die 220.000 Beschäftigten bekommen ab sofort 3, 4 Prozent mehr Lohn. Bei Tests in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern sind mit Nitrophäen belastete Eier und Geflügelfleisch gefunden worden. Landwirtschaftsminister Backhaus teilte mit, die Werte erreichten zum Teil das 18-fache des Erlaubten. Er geht davon aus, dass mehrere 10.000 Legehennen getötet werden müssen. Das Finanzloch im brandenburgischen Haushalt ist deutlich größer als bisher erwartet. Insgesamt kommen 350 Millionen Euro mehr Belastung auf das Land zu, sagte Finanzministerin Ziegler. Allein die Steuerausfälle betrügen nach jüngsten Schätzungen im laufenden Jahr bis zu 244 Millionen Euro. Großbritanniens Außenminister Straw hat sich optimistisch geäußert, dass ein Krieg zwischen Indien und Pakistan vermieden werden kann. Straw sagte in Neu-Deli, die Lage sei zwar gefährlich, es gebe aber noch Raum für eine politische Lösung. Im Osten Afghanistans haben die internationalen Truppen eine neue Militäraktion gegen Taliban-Kämpfer begonnen. Nach Angaben eines britischen Militärsprechers wurden rund 300 Marineinfanteristen in die Nähe der pakistanischen Grenze verlegt. Und zum Sport. Nach zehn Etappen im rosa Trikot hat Telekom-Profi Jens Heppner die Führung im Giro d'Italia abgegeben. Neuer Spitzenreiter ist der Australier Kedell Evans. Die Verkehrsmeldungen A10, Autobahn Dreieck Potsdam, Schönefelder Kreuz zwischen Rassstätte Michendorf und Potsdam Süd ist wegen eines Unfalls der linke Fahrstreifen blockiert. Nochmal A10, Autobahn Dreieck Potsdam, Schönefelder Kreuz zwischen Rassstätte Michendorf und Drebitz Nutetal ist die Fahrbahn wegen Bauarbeiten auf einen Fahrstreifen verengt. A9, Potsdam Halle Leipzig zwischen Belitz und Brück ist wegen eines Unfalls der rechte Fahrstreifen gesperrt. Stadtverkehr Berlin A111, Berlin Charlottenburg Autobahn Dreieck Oranienburg zwischen Kurt-Schumacher-Damm und Tunnel Flughafen Tegel derzeit ein Kilometer Stau. Und A100 Wilmersdorf Lichtenberg im Ortskern Britz ist wegen Bauarbeiten der rechte Fahrstreifen gesperrt.
Romantisch, chaotisch, karomatisch und ungefähr nachmittags zerstärkt Karoma Club für dich und mit dir.
Deine brennenden Fragen, deine Lieblingsmusik, deine Geschichten dazu, deine Freunde, deine Feinde, dein Leben.
Am Samstag mit dabei sein kannst jetzt sofort klarklicken fritz.de neu und im Radio immer samstags von 14 bis 18 Uhr.
Fritz Wouh! Chaosradio 72 auf Fritz. Um Datensammler geht's. Am Telefon ist immer noch Rena vom Füllbud. Sag nochmal was Füllbud ist, Rena.
Vereinsverförderung des öffentlichen bewegten und unbewegten Datenverkehrs. Toll. Denkt da weiter bitte nicht drüber nach, sondern guckt ansonsten lieber auf www.bigbrotherawards.de und da gibt's mehr.
Alles klar, die Verleihung dessen wird nämlich vom Füllbud organisiert. Wir waren eben bei den Paybackkarten, die ja ausschließlich dazu dienen, Daten zu sammeln und ihr habt da was gegen unternommen.
Ihr habt diese Privacy-Card gemacht.
Ja, wir dachten uns, es ist blöd einfach immer nur den Zeigefinger zu heben und sagen, das ist gefährlich, mach das nicht. Sondern wir haben uns dann überlegt, wir machen einfach da mal was Nettes und haben eine eigene Karte herausgegeben. Und diese Karte ist die tausendfache Kopie von einer solchen Kundenkarte, vielmehr von der Mitbenutzerkarte, die man dann immer bekommt. Und insofern können tausend Leute mit uns zusammen sammeln. Auf dieselbe Kundennummer wohlgemerkt. Das Kundenprofil, was dabei rauskommt, dürfte interessant sein.
Oder auch nicht unbrauchbar. Was hat Paybox dazu gesagt? Die haben dich bestimmt von Cardi gezerrt, oder nicht?
Nein, nein. Keineswegs. Denn diese Art der Nutzung ist nach deutschem Recht keineswegs illegal, weil ich meine, es findet kein Betrug statt oder kein Missbrauch. Denn die Umsätze werden ja tatsächlich gemacht. Die Leute kaufen ja tatsächlich ein. Also für den Umsatz steht einem ein Rabatt zu.
Und die Zweitkarte ist nicht personengebunden, oder?
Und es widerspricht nicht mal den Teilnahmebedingungen von Payback, egal wie sie sich drehen und winden. Und deswegen zerrt uns keineswegs Payback vor den Cardi, sondern wir zerren Payback vor den Cardi, weil wir möchten, dass sie diesen Vertrag auch vertragsgemäß fortsetzen.
Kann ich eine Kopie von der Karte haben? Kann ich auch eine Kopie von der Karte haben?
Selbstverständlich. Gehe einfach auf www.fürbot.org. Ich sag nochmal F-O-E-B-U-D.
Das kommt in der Linkliste mit uns rum.
Und da findest du unter dem Punkt Privacy Card alles an Infos. Und mittlerweile mussten wir nachproduzieren, weil die Nachfrage so stark ist.
Ja großartig, immer mit.
Wie hoch ist denn der Punktestand? Wie viele Punkte hatten wir da jetzt zusammen gesammelt?
Das kann man leider grad nicht sagen. Wir hatten vorher einen Skript geschrieben, um das bei TAYBACK immer aktuell abzufragen. 23.458 ist der letzte Stand.
Und was wir daneben haben, kann man nicht sehen.
Und wir klagen auch deshalb, weil wir sehen wollen, wie viele Punkte wir tatsächlich haben. Denn mittlerweile wird natürlich viel mehr gesammelt als vorher, weil es viel bekannter ist.
Wie viel, wie viel würdest du bekommen für 23.000 Punkte?
Oh, wir haben uns das Laufen schon auszahlen lassen. Also wir haben etwa 460 Mark dafür an Rabatten bekommen.
Das war anständig.
Nö, das ist eigentlich ziemlich uninteressant, wenn du überlegst, wie viele Leute dafür einkaufen waren. Die Herstellungskosten der Karte sind weitaus höher als das. Das ist aber nicht der Punkt, sondern diese Karte macht Leuten sehr schön klar, was eigentlich mit diesen, was ansonsten mit Paybackkarten los ist und worin sich die Privacy Card unterscheidet. Die hat auch ein eigenes Design, ganz hübsch. Und da steht genau drauf, was sie macht.
Das ist für uns auch sehr, sehr lustig, mit der Karte einkaufen zu gehen. Ich hatte das auch schon, dass ich im Real stand und die gute Frau sagt, was ist das für eine Karte? Und du meintest, nee, nee, ist schon okay, einfach ganz gerne ziehen. Und ich so, nee, nee, also das geht ja nicht. Ich kenne die Karte nicht und das ist ja kein Partnerunternehmen, das kann man nicht machen. Ich so, nee, ist schon okay, ziehen Sie mal einfach rüber. Dann hat sie auch noch ihre Vorsitzende oder sowas da geholt. Und die guckte so, no, ziehen Sie mal rüber. Und dann piep, war natürlich dann alles in Ordnung. Die guckte ein bisschen verdutzt und damit war das dann auch ein bisschen.
Was wir eigentlich noch nicht so viel geredet haben, ist eigentlich, was eigentlich passiert mit den Kundendaten. Also wozu die dienen, dass man zum Beispiel Kunden auch dann so Scores gibt, dass man sagt, das ist also ein A-Kunde, das ist ein B-Kunde, das ist ein C-Kunde, dass man sich anguckt, in welcher Wohngegend die wohnen und so weiter. Und bevor wir dich da fragen noch gleich, Rena, ich fand diese Story von dir, Frank, so unheimlich gut, weil das macht so klar, also wenn ich, wenn du jetzt irgendwie bei Payback bist.
Welche Story denn?
Ich hatte, ich wollte einfach im Internet einen MP3-Player bestellen, so wie man das halt so mal macht. Und da dachte ich mir, da war so ein Klickfeld, prima, hier können sie einfach bestellen und dann per Rechnung bezahlen. Da dachte ich mir, prima, meine Angaben ausgefüllt, ist ja bequem und dann kam so eine Antwort vom Server, es geht leider aus technischen Gründen gerade nicht. Da hab ich mir halt mal zwei, drei Tage angeguckt, dachte naja gut, kann ja sein. Und dann hab ich mal die Hotline angerufen und dann fragte er mich, ja haben sie denn auch ihr Geburtsdatum angegeben mit der Bankverbindung? Geburtsdatum? Warum denn? So naja, das brauchen wir, um zu prüfen, ob die Bankverbindung stimmt. Sie können ja nicht bei der Bank, die Bank rückt ja nicht mein Geburtsdatum raus und überprüft sowas, was erzählen sie mir denn? Na ja, wir brauchen das hier. Gut, dann kann ich ja irgendwas eingeben, wenn sie das sowieso nicht überprüfen wollte. Meinst du ja, ok, sie sind nah dran. So, dann ist mir irgendwie der Kragen geplatzt und ich hab den Typ durchs Telefon gezogen und hab gesagt, ok, erklären sie mir jetzt, was die Sache ist. Na ja gut, dann hat er mir halt erklärt, dass sie da halt bestimmte Verfahren haben. Und dann ging es weiter noch zur Anschrift und Postleitzahl. Und dann ging das wieder nicht, kam wieder ein Serverfehler. Und dann meinte er, ja dann liegt das wahrscheinlich an der Postleitzahl. So, dann hatte ich ja schon so eine böse Vorahnung. Und was da passiert ist. Vielleicht kannst du uns da irgendwie kurz was zu sagen zu diesem, ja wie sagt man, wie heißt so ein Verfahren? Der Score-Wert.
Score-Wert.
Score-Wert?
Was bedeuten Postleitzahlen für die Menschen? Eine Straße, in der sie wohnen.
Also der Score-Wert gibt in einer einzigen Zahl wieder wie wünschenswert als Kunde oder Kundin du bist. Also wie kreditwürdig. Und eine Firma, die noch keinerlei Erfahrung mit dir hat, beurteilt dich einfach aufgrund eines Score-Werts, der aus ominösen Daten errechnet worden ist, von denen du nicht weißt, auf Grundlage welcher Daten es errechnet wird. So etwas macht zum Beispiel die Schufa. Aber auch andere Firmen, also die Schufa ist ja allgemein bekannt. Aber es gibt dann auch so ganz unauffällig benahmste Firmen, wie die Informer Unternehmensberatung GmbH in Pforzheim. Und die macht das mittlerweile für viele Firmen, die im Internet irgendeinen Shop laufen haben. Und da geht das dann sozusagen voll automatisch. Das heißt, sobald du deine Adresse eintippst, wird entschieden, der wird beliefert, der auf Vorkasse und der darf auch auf Rechnung bezahlen.
Und du meintest vorhin, die Informer, die haben auch einen...
Zement mal, nur weil ich in einem sozialen Brennpunkt wohne, darf ich nicht auf Rechnung kaufen.
Oder weil deine Nachbarn zum Beispiel die Rechnung bei Quelle nicht bezahlt haben.
Richtig, also die Erfahrungen zum Beispiel, die die großen Versandhäuser gemacht haben, gehen damit ein. Dein Alter, also deswegen beuten die das Geburtsdatum. Also wenn du 18 bist, hast du prinzipiell einen schlechten Scorewert. Wenn du 50 bist, dann einen guten, weil das statistisch ist, dass Leute, die um die 50 sind, doch häufiger ihre Rechnung dann tatsächlich bezahlen.
Gut zu wissen.
Und es gibt viele andere Sachen, die da noch mit eingehen, aber es werden wie gesagt gar nicht alle offen gelegt. Deswegen kannst du auch gar nicht protestieren und sagen halt, mein Scorewert ist falsch. Die meisten Leute wissen nicht mal, dass sowas existiert und dass sie aufgrund von einer einzigen Zahl bewertet werden, deren Grundlage sie nicht kennen. Das ist ein Problem. Das ist eine Machtfrage. Das heißt einfach, Leute wissen nicht, dass über sie geurteilt wird. Also die wissen vielleicht, ich habe dieser und jener Firma diese und jene Informationen gegeben. Die haben zum Beispiel an einer netten Konsumentenbefragung teilgenommen, haben sechs Seiten ausgefüllt, was sie sich denn wünschen würden. Sie hätten gerne ein DVD-Player-Video, haben sie schon und das und das. Und neben damit einen Preis ausschreiben für eine Digitalkamera-Teil. Was sie nicht wissen, ist, dass das alles mit ausgewertet wird, um hinterher zu sagen, dem Typ schicken wir auf gar keinen Fall irgendwas, wenn wir nicht Vorkasse bekommen haben.
Lena, ich denke der Föbut, der dürfte ja auch Anwälte haben. Dieses Scoring aufgrund meines Wohnortes, das klingt mir nach einem Verfassungsbruch. Artikel 1, die Würde des Menschen ist unantastbar und die wird in diesem Fall doch angetastet.
Ja, das ist aber ganz trickreich. Wir haben ein relativ gutes Bundesdatenschutzgesetz und da steht drin, das nennt man automatisierte Einzelentscheidung. Das eigentlich darf nicht aufgrund von diesem Scorewert alleine entschieden werden, ob du jetzt eine Lieferung bekommst oder nicht. Deswegen werden die Kunden von der Informer dazu verpflichtet, auch von der Schufa, dass sie noch weitere Entscheidungsgründe eigentlich heranziehen müssen. Aber ob sie das tatsächlich tun, das kann ihnen ja niemand nachweisen. Das heißt, de jure ist es so, dass es eigentlich nicht zulässig wäre, de facto ist das nicht nachzuweisen. Und bisher war es tatsächlich sogar so bei der Schufa, wenn du Auskunft eingeholt hast über deine über dich gespeicherten Daten, was ja dein gutes Recht ist, bei jeder Firma kannst du das tun, dann ist dein Scorewert automatisch gesunken. Und zwar für die Leute dort, logische Begründung, wenn jemand einen Verbraucher nach seinem Scorewert fragt, nein, nicht nach seinem Scorewert, wenn ein Verbraucher eine eigene Auskunft haben will, dann hat er offensichtlich etwas vor, sei es ein Haus kaufen, sei es ein Zuliebaufnehmen, irgendwas. Wenn jemand so etwas vorhat, dann kann auch was schiefgehen. Also das Risiko erhöht sich, also gehen wir mit dem Scorewert vorsichtshalber gleich etwas runter.
Ist so etwas erledigt?
Das ist mittlerweile unzulässig, die Schufa tut das wohl auch nicht mehr.
Es ist ein Fass ohne Boden. Rena vom Föhrboot war das. Falls ihr den Föhrboot ansurfen wollt www.foebud.de Nee Org, ne? Org, verzeihung. DE funktioniert auch. Oder Org. Vielen Dank Rena. Die Musik heute wird übrigens live aufgelegt von LN eine DJin, die hier tatsächlich im Studio steht. Na ja, gut, das ist Chaosradio 72 auf Fritz im Studio. Der Frank. Ich, es ist zum Kotzen. Mein Namensgedächtnis, Sarah, so Entschuldigung, es ist mein Namensgedächtnis ist die Hölle. Wir müssen hier gerade mal was off erklären, liebe Höhrende. Und dann machen wir weiter. Nein, der Frank, die Sache an den Knöpfen steht Holger Klein, wie ihr am Gestammel unschwer erkennen könnt. Und der Blue Moon, um den es sich hier handelt, ist ja im Prinzip eine Sendung, die dazu da ist, dass Höhrende dort anrufen, um mitzureden. Und das hier ist die Nummer.
0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110.
Und jetzt kommt die Frage.
Ja, wir wollen von euch wissen, welche Punkte sammelt ihr? Sammelt ihr die Payback-Punkte oder die Poopsie-Punkte? Sammelt ihr überhaupt Punkte? Wenn ja, warum nicht? Oder vertraut ihr den Firmen, was sie mit euren Daten machen? Und wie sieht es da aus? Wie seht ihr so eine Bonusprogramme? Seid ihr dabei? Findet ihr das toll, dass ihr nur Zielgruppengewächte in Werbung kommt? Oder wie sieht es da aus?
Und zwar hier. Chaosradio, hallo.
Ey, da ist schon jemand.
Wenn die Telefonanlage das wäre so. Ist da jemand?
Ja, hallo.
Hey, Wahnsinn. Gratuliere. Du hast die Telefonanlage überlebt.
Bin ich jetzt schon live auf Sendung?
Du bist auf Sendung, ja.
Oh, du einmal gewählt, weißt du gleich rein ohne Aufnahmeleiter. Ja hallo, ich hab eine Frage. Also diese ganze T-Deck-Scheiße, mir ehe so speckt. Da geh ich nicht ran, aber ich hab zum Beispiel ein altes Haus im Bauderfiel.
Wenn du da nicht rangehst, geh doch bitte ein bisschen ans Telefon ran mit deinem Mund.
Ja, so zum Beispiel?
Ja, so zum Beispiel.
Ah, besser, ne? Ich hab so ein altes Haus und kaufe viel in Baumärkten. Da kriegt man dann so wie am Jahresende, wenn man eine bestimmte Summe eingekauft hat, so drei bis vier Prozent Rabatt. Und wenn ich eure Sendung sehe, bin ich mir natürlich extrem unsicher, ob da nicht auch irgendein Profil verarbeitet wird oder ob das einfach mal so ein Rabatt ist, damit einfach mal Firmen oder Leute, die viel einkaufen, einfach nur gebunden werden.
Frag doch da mal nach beim Baumarkt.
Die werden es ihm nicht sagen. Ich mein, machen wir uns doch mal nichts vor. Sollen sie mal nicht um ihr Rabatt einzuräumen oder wollen sie mich auch durchleuchten?
Wie funktioniert denn das da im Baumarkt? Gibt es da auch so eine Karte mit so einem Barcode drauf oder wie läuft das?
Nee, den gibt es nicht. Man kauft einen und gibt danach die Rechnung ab und hat einen dicken Ordner, wirklich nur mit Name und Adresse, keine Kontonummer und Bar-Auszahlung. Und natürlich gibt es dann immer diese dicken Prospekte mit Preisausschreiben und diesem ganzen Dreck. Aber das muss man ja nicht ausfüllen. Also da habt ihr nämlich irgendwie Erfahrungen oder sowas mit gesammelt.
Also solange da irgendwelche Papierzettel, die bei dir dann auch noch bleiben, oder liegen die denn da?
Die bleiben im Baumarkt, die werden dann in dicken Ordnern abgeheftet. Und dann, wenn man genug eingekauft hat, kriegt man auch wieder an irgendeiner Aktion, kriegt man dann wieder zehn Prozent darauf und zehn Prozent darauf.
Dann haben die es vielleicht noch nicht ganz begriffen oder so.
Aber vielleicht, wenn man hat so, gibst du deinen Namen und deine Anschrift, gibst du aber damit ab, ne?
Name, Anschrift, Telefonnummer, mehr aber auch nicht.
Was man natürlich jetzt damit machen kann, ist, dass man guckt, was interessiert dich eigentlich, also was für Produkte kaufst du dort. Und auf Basis, dass dieses Profil, also alles, was du gekauft hast, wird gebündelt mit deinem Namen zusammengetan und dann wird dir entsprechende Werbung zugeschickt. Ich nehme an, dass du wahrscheinlich auch mal Post bekommst von dem Baumarkt hin und wieder. Ja, siehst du, dann kann es zum Beispiel sein, dass diese Profilinformation mit deiner Adresse weitergegeben worden ist an andere Stellen. Hast du vielleicht irgendwann mal unterschrieben, dass du einwilligst, dass deine Daten zur Verarbeitung anderweitig weitergegeben werden?
Ich glaube nicht, dass sich jemand wirklich um dieses Kreuz kümmert.
Aber sag mal, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel der Baumarkt ankommen würde, würde sagen, okay, sie kriegen jetzt nicht nur 3 Prozent Rabatt von uns, sondern 5 Prozent oder 7 Prozent, wenn sie da noch ein bisschen mehr was ausfüllen. Zum Beispiel, was fahren sie denn für ein Auto? Wie viele Leute leben hier im Haushalt? Wo kaufen sie sonst noch einen? Könntest du dir das vorstellen, um dann noch mehr Rabattpunkte zu kriegen, so was auszufüllen?
Nee, das meine ich grundsätzlich nicht. Ich weiß ganz einfach auch aus anderen Quellen, ganz einfach, dass diese Adressen halt für unheimlich viel Geld gehandelt werden. Eine gut recherchierte Adresse gibt bis zu 5.000 Mark. Und da muss ich mich nicht dran beteiligen.
Bitte was? Ist das zugen? Nee, 5.000, das glaube ich nicht. Aber es ist schon je nachdem, wie wertvoll. Also ja, es kann schon sein, dass irgendwelche Top-Manager oder sowas, gut, 5.000 Mark würde ich jetzt mal nicht ausschließen. Aber was wäre denn so ein Betrag, den du dir vorstellen könntest, zu erhalten zu wollen, um dann irgendwie so Angaben über dein Familienleben zu machen? Ja, nee, aber ist klar, aber als Prämie. Also sagen wir mal, die geben dir nicht nur drei Prozent oder vier Prozent, sondern die geben dir einfach irgendwie 50 Euro Cash auf die Hand, wenn du so ein Ding da ausfüllst.
Nee, ist mir egal, mach ich ja einfach aus Prinzip.
Auch nicht 100?
Nein, ist mir egal, weil meine persönlichen Daten sind mir einfach heilig. Also wenn es an die Kontonummer geht, mit Überweisung geht, spiele ich da auch nicht mehr mit, weil das hat einfach niemanden zu interessieren. Das ist meine Privatsphäre und die wird überhaupt eingedrungen. Ich habe einen Telefax und habe irgendwann mal den größten Fehler, den man machen kann. Wenn man einen Telefax kauft, kriegt man ja so ein Probe-Shirt dabei, so ein Test-Shirt für Telefax, dass man eine Telekom zu uns senden kann und das Telefax auch wirklich gut funktioniert.
Und dann schütten sie dich mit Fax-Werbung zu, ne?
Ja, dann kommt man in diese Com-Page, heißt das. Das ist so ein bisschen Telefax-Verzeichnis. Ich habe auch noch eine kleine Firma. Und dann bist du da drin und dann nachts klingelt ständig das Telefon, weil irgendwelche Werbe-Faxe kommen und darüber kriegen sie dann auch die Handynummer raus, weil die dann auch irgendwie im Telefonbuch darüber erschienen ist, was gar nicht sein sollte. Und Telekom hatte ja schon dieses Reizthema. Wie die die Daten breit treten und veröffentlichen, das ist dann schon nervend genug. Und deshalb, wo ich vermeiden kann, vermeide ich auch, irgendwelche Daten anzugeben. Ich liebe es auch, Anträge halb ausgefüllt nur anzugeben. Und wirklich nur Name, Adresse, Anschrift, Geburtsdatum, Beruf lasse ich grundsätzlich weg. Und dann wirklich nur, wo es notwendig ist.
Gute Nacht noch, tschüss. Wollte er noch?
Nee, nee, warte mal. Okay, gut.
033170. Ich mach das mal verständlich. 03317097110 ist die Fritz Hotline. Wir würden ganz gerne von euch wissen, wie ihr mit Daten umgeht.
Nicht wie ihr mit Daten umgeht, sondern wie ihr sie schützt. Genau.
Wie ihr sie schützt. Naja, vielleicht gibt es auch genug Leute, die sagen, ich schütze meine Daten nicht, weil ich hab ja nichts zu verbergen.
Außerdem gibt es da tolle Punkte und tolle Prämien.
Genau, tolle Prämien hier unter 033170971. Ihr müsst nur eure Kontonummer, das Geburtsdatum und den Mädchennamen eurer Mutter dalassen.
Chaosradio, hallo.
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich zur Sendung ein bisschen was sagen. Und zwar hasse ich diese ganze Datensammlung. Wie kann man sich überhaupt dagegen schützen und so weiter?
Das war eine Frage, wie kann man sich schützen, oder?
Nee, nee, so eine Art Themenansatz war. Ich mein, guckt euch doch mal um, wenn das wirklich so weitergeht und so weiter. Mit dieser ganzen Datensammlung, ich mein, wo soll das im Endeffekt hinführen?
Ja, aber das Problem ist, die Leute machen doch mit. Also das, ich mein, okay, ist ja toll, dass die Firmen, also die haben ja natürlich ein Adresse da dran.
Entschuldigung, die Leute gucken auch RTL 2.
Ja.
Die fressen alles, was man ihnen vorwirft, muss man einfach mal sagen. Entschuldigung, entschuldigt Leute.
Database Nation.
Du sammelst keine Punkte, hast keine Bonuskarten, keine Rabattkarten.
Ich versuch mich da auf jeden Fall irgendwie rauszuhalten. Nur ich mein, ich hab jetzt grad mal so ein bisschen zugehört und hab versucht zu überlegen, wo hab ich jetzt irgendwo schon Angaben gemacht.
Hast du einen E-Mail-Account bei so einem Web-Mail-Anbieter?
Bei welchem?
Und hab wirklich nur das nötigste ausgefüllt und irgendwie irgendwann hat's Klick gemacht und dann wurde ich nur noch mit irgendwelchen Sexbomben da irgendwie zugemeldet. Das ist echt zum Kotzen.
Du bist auf die falschen Seiten gegangen.
Ja, gut. Und hast die Cookies hinterher nicht gelöscht? Und hast die Cookies hinterher nicht gelöscht?
Ja, vielleicht auch das.
Aber das kenn ich mich nicht so genau aus.
Ja, da kommen wir auch nachher nochmal ein bisschen zu, was so Web-Geschichten angeht. Also bei Yahoo, da weiß ich zum Beispiel, dass die hunderte von Segmenten haben. Das ist in dem Moment, wo du auf eine Seite gehst und du hast jetzt den Cookie nicht gelöscht, dass du sofort also eingeteilt wirst in eine von diesen Minigruppen. Und das ist nicht nur auf Basis von Daten, die du jetzt explizit mal dargelassen hast, vielleicht auch in einem MyYahoo-Bereich, sondern das sind auch zum Beispiel die Navigationshistorie, die du während du Surfs hinterlässt. Also das nennen die Current Mode. Das heißt also, du gehst jetzt in den Bereich Reisen, du gehst in den Bereich Italien und du merkst einfach, dass sich die Werbung automatisch deinem hier inhaltlichen... Die Banner-Werbung.
Ja, welche Werbung?
Dass die sich deinem Interesse... Die Banner-Werbung, die dir bei Yahoo!
eingespielt wird.
Ab und zu. Dann hast du aber ab und zu das Problem, dass dir ganze Seiten gar nicht angezeigt werden, ne?
Ja mein Gott, für den einen Punkt, wenn man meinetwegen auf irgendwelchen Underground-Seiten rumschlawinert, dann macht man den mal kurz aus für die eine Seite und hinterher mache ich den wieder an, ändert. Das finde ich halt echt scheiße. Guckt euch doch mal um. Überall werden Daten gesammelt. Wo soll das enden? Wo soll das hinführen? Was haben die Leute davon? Okay, die Anwendungsgebiete haben wir jetzt schon gehört. Aber ich meine, Hallo? Vertraut hier wirklich keine mehr dem anderen? Ich meine, das ist gut.
Offensichtlich ja schon. Also sonst würden 17 Millionen Leute nicht bereit, will ich ihre Payback, ihre Daten an Payback geben. Die müssen sehr viel Vertrauen haben eigentlich.
Nennen wir das mal nicht mal Vertrauen, sondern nennen wir das mal vielleicht mal ein bisschen Dummheit oder Nicht-Wissen.
Na okay, weil du es bist.
Ich würde damit besser zurechtkommen, wenn ich wüsste, was wirklich mit meinem Daten passiert. Na ganz ehrlich.
Kriegen wir das irgendwo raus?
Ja, bei den Betrieben selber.
Unter vorgehaltener Hand vielleicht, wenn man...
Wahrscheinlich nicht unter vorgehaltener Hand, sondern in einer mit vorgehaltenen Waffe, oder?
Gut, okay.
Das war kein Aufruf jetzt. Ganz im Gegenteil.
Überleg euch mal, ihr geht in den Baumarkt, wie du von schon sagtest, und fragst, was passiert. Die werden mir garantiert nicht rein Wein einschenken.
Sie wissen es ja nicht mehr. Das ist ja das Problem. Ich hab mich auch schon mal mit einer Verkäuferin bei ReaL angelegt, die mich fragte, ob ich eine Paybackkarte haben will. Und ich auch gefragt, was machen sie damit mit meinen Daten? Und das hat die so aus der Fassung gebracht. Ich hab mir gesagt, nee, das war nur ein Scherz. Ich hab bezahlt und bin gegangen.
Nee, also ich würde mich wirklich generell dafür aussprechen, dass sowas generell verboten wird.
Echt.
Ich hasse sowas wie die Pest.
Aber das Problem ist halt...
Den kenn ich nicht, da muss ich mich halt im Gespräch oder wenn ich ihn kennenlerne, da kann ich mich wie ihr von meintet, wie so einen sogenannten Scorewert, das ist zu kosten. Eine Zahl repräsentiert einen Menschen.
Hallo?
Wenn ich dir erzähle, aus welchem Bezirk ich komme, dann ordnest du mich aber auch schon rein.
Nicht wirklich, ich bin kiezgebunden.
Alles klar. Micha, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Gute Nacht, tschüss. Ich lass mal eben ansagen. Und zwar Chaosradio 72, wir telefonieren gleich weiter. Chaosradio 72 ist hier 0331-7791, das ist die Nummer der Fritz-Watt-Line und wir reden immer noch darüber, wie ihr eure Daten schützt bzw. welche ihr für schützenswert haltet und welche ihr vielleicht dummerweise schon rausgegeben habt. Und wenn ihr eine Frage habt, wie ihr euch schützen könnt, dann sind hier auch mindestens zwei kompetente Menschen im Studio, auch höchstens, also mindestens und höchstens zwei kompetente Menschen im Studio, die euch diese Fragen beantworten können. 0331-779110, guten Abend, hier ist Chaosradio.
Ich hab mal eine Frage, die Adresse von den kopierten Karten. www.
FOEBUD, Füllbud. FOEBUD, Friedrich Otto, Emil Bertha, Ulrich dora.org.
Ansonsten bist du im Chaosradio Updateverteiler? Da schicken wir das dann noch rum. Dann subscrib dich da einfach mal. Das geht über chaosradio.ccc.de. Da ist eine Adresse, das ist so ein Mailverteiler, da kannst du dich subscriben. Und da schicken wir jetzt nach der Sendung irgendwann morgen oder sowas wahrscheinlich die ganzen Sachen auch rum. Die ganzen Links. Ansonsten geht auch auf www. ccc.de. Da ist auch ein Artikel, so eine Update-Meldung, die ist aber schon ein bisschen älter. Zu dieser Privacy Card und was sie damit genau auf sich hat, das kannst du auch noch mal nachlesen. Da gibt es dann auch die Bestelladresse nochmal. Auch für alle anderen die nochmal.
Und das war's schon?
Wie gesagt, ich wollte als Praxisbeispiel angehen. Ich wohne hier im Jugendwohnheim, bin hier nicht gemeldet. Und meine Adresse von hier haben einmal die Berliner Zeitung und einmal der Atlas Verlag oder so. Mittlerweile kriege ich Posts von der Post AG Abteilung Philatterie. Und die versuchen mir jetzt aufs Tisch, was ich um den Briefmarken sammeln soll.
Aber du kriegst auch da normale Briefpost hin, oder? Nein, ich kriege da eigentlich keine Post hin.
Wie gesagt, ich bin ja nicht gemeldet. Das sind eigentlich die heißesten Stellen, die irgendwann von mir meine Adresse gekriegt haben.
Aber du hast bestimmt von den Zeitungen, die du da hast, diese wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Probe-Abos oder so, hast du doch bestimmt auch mal einen Brief gekriegt dahin.
Ja, wie gesagt, die Berliner Zeitung schickt immer mal wieder was. Die wollen immer mal wieder, dass ich nichts mehr melde und so.
Gut, aber dann kriegst du ja doch Post dahin. Ja, du kriegst aber Post von denen. Das heißt, die Post weist dann natürlich auch deine Adresse da.
Meint ihr wirklich, dass die Post guckt, ah, der kriegt Post dahin und wie gesagt, also soweit ich weiß, bin ich der Einzelste hier im Wohnheim, der das gekriegt hat bis jetzt.
Frag doch mal nach, wo sie deine Adresse her haben. Ganz einfach.
Einmal anrufen und fragen.
Ich war bei der Post gewesen, hier bei unserer örtlichen Poststelle und da war dann so eine Meinung, ich kriege hier von ihnen Post und hab ihnen nicht mal meine Adresse gegeben, wo sie nicht mal irgendwelche Infos haben. Die meinten, ja, wir sind eine toffe Gesellschaft, wir können da nichts dafür.
Genau, richtig. Frag mal bei der, was ist das deutsche Postwehrzeichen oder was ist das da, keine Ahnung.
Oder frag mal bei der Berliner Zeitung nach, was die mit der Adresse gemacht haben, an die sie dir die Zeitung schicken. Und ob sie vielleicht diese Adressen weiterverkaufen. Das könnte ja auch sein. Es gibt halt häufig, gerade bei Adressen, gibt es undichte Löcher. Die werden eben gehandelt und man weiß immer nicht so genau.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich hab nur so mal durchgeguckt und wirklich die beiden einfächsten Stellen, von denen ich Post kriege, weil ich bei denen mal irgendwas geordert habe. Wie gesagt, ein Probeabo oder mal hier mal gucken.
Ja, die Probeabo müssen sich auch rentieren. Die rechnen ja schon nicht damit, dass die Leute dahinter her... Also ich will das jetzt gar nicht unterstellen, aber...
Na, hast du aber. Und weißt du auch womit?
Mit Recht.
Hast du irgendwelche Bonuskarten ansonsten?
Nee, hab ich nicht. Also wie gesagt, ich hab drüber nachgedacht, aber seit ich jetzt so die Diskussion höre, ich hör jetzt so im Moment zu. Also wäre ich denn doch schon echt.
Okay, dann danken wir dir für den Anruf.
Und Auftrag erfüllt.
Danke.
Das ist echt tragisch, dass die Menschen so eine unglaublich schwere Kindheit hatten. Das ist wirklich schade. Okay, einen Versuch machen wir noch, danach gehen wir nicht mehr ins Telefon. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio.
Ich hab zwei Runde Äpfel und ein süßes Traumwitz.
Hier wäre mein Glück heute.
Kommen wir vielleicht zum Internet?
Genau, das Internet. Das wird sowieso bald verboten, die verbieten bald das Internet.
Aber das sammelt sich ja wirklich dumm und dämlich, oder?
Ja, wenn man im Internet surft, dann hat man ja eigentlich, wenn man zu Hause sitzt, auch manchmal den Eindruck, man ist eigentlich, ja keiner beobachtet einen, keiner sieht, was man eigentlich tut, welche Seite man anstarrt. Und das ist natürlich Quatsch, denn die Server, die einem quasi die Seiten schicken, die haben sogenannte Logfiles. Und in diesen Logfiles wird eben aufgezeichnet, also wer die Requests macht, das heißt also die IP-Adresse verrät schonmal, wo kommt eigentlich die Anfrage her, aus welcher Domain. Ich surf ich beispielsweise eine Amazon-Seite an von der Uni, von der HU-Berlin vielleicht sogar. Also man kann relativ genau nachvollziehen in den Logfiles, woher kommt eine Anfrage, wann war die Anfrage. Es gibt andere Daten, zum Beispiel von allen anderen Seiten, wo ich gekommen bin auf die Amazon-Seite beispielsweise, über den Referrer. Es gibt Angaben natürlich, wie ich mich durch die Seite bewegt habe. Also die Logfiles sind sehr aussagekräftig. Was für ein Rechner ich überhaupt habe, was für ein Betriebssystem, welche Browser-Version. Gut, das sind eben teilweise Daten, die der Host braucht, um eben auch die Inhalte gerecht runterzuschicken. Aber eben die Erweiterung eben zu wissen, zum Beispiel auch über das Setzen von einem Cookie, ob ich wiedergekommen bin.
Ja, aber das geht doch glaube ich sogar noch weiter. Also, dass irgendwelche Webseiten in der Lage sind, mir zu sagen, welche Version von Word ich benutze. Oder nicht? Gibt es denn nicht auch irgendwelche Möglichkeiten, dass es ausgelesen wird irgendwo?
Also, meinen Browser gibt sowas bestimmt nicht raus, aber...
Nee, ich weiß es nicht. Es ist mir auch nochmal kolportiert worden, dass es irgendwie möglich sei, aus Systemateien auszulesen.
Du kannst über so ActiveX-Controls, die denn so irgendwelche Browser-Lücken ausnutzen. Das wird aber glaube ich nicht flächendeckend gemacht. Weil einfach die Browser-Versionen zu sehr unterschiedlich sind und vor so einer Technologie wirklich funktionierend marktraff entwickelt ist. Es gibt schon wieder nächste Browser-Versionen, wo das dann gefixt ist. Also das glaube ich nicht, dass es so eine... Aber gerade Geschichten wie Cookies oder auch Web-Bugs waren ja mal sehr in Mode. Das sind also kleine Mini-Gifts, kleine Mini-Bildchen, irgendwie 0x0 Pixel oder sowas, oder 1x1 Pixel, die dann unsichtbar an der Seite platziert worden sind, aber dann auch von einem anderen Server kommen können. Und die werden dann mit einem Namen versehen, der einmalig ist. Das heißt also, darüber kriege ich dann, ich kann im Serverlog eben den einmaligen Namen, diese einmalige URL, dann aufspüren und mit der dann auch arbeiten, wenn es darum geht, diesen Clickstream, sagt man dazu auch, also wie ich mich durch die Seiten klicke, dann zu verfolgen.
Genau, das machen, setzen eben auch vor allen Dingen gerne Werbefirmen ein, weil sie eben wissen möchten, ob jemand auch den Banner gesehen hat. Also hat das Sehen eines Banners wirklich hinterher auch zum Kauf geführt bei einer entsprechenden Firma und um diesen Transfer zu leisten, muss man ja wissen, was hat der Kunde gesehen, und das kann man eben durch Webbugs realisieren. Ich meine vor allen Dingen, neben den Webbugs, wie gesagt, die Cookies, da sind wir jetzt nicht so stark drauf eingegangen. Da gibt es eben, wie gesagt, auch diese Third-Party Cookies, sprich ich gehe auf eine Seite von Amazon, kriege ich aber Werbung von einer Bank, da setzt mir die Bank aber auch ein Cookie. Also nicht nur derjenige, den ich besuche, setzt mir etwas auf meinen Rechner, ohne es mir zu sagen, sondern auch noch die anderen Leute, die drum herum mich eigentlich gar nicht interessieren.
Was bei Amazon sowieso auch noch super nervig ist, also ich schmeiße meine Cookies, meine Cookies werden immer gelöscht, wenn ich meinen Rechner ausschalte. Und wenn ich dann das nächste Mal zu Amazon komme, dann wollen die, wollen mir jedes Mal, wenn ich auf diese Seite komme, weil sie nicht wissen, wer ich bin, so einen dämlichen Geschenkgutschein überhelfen. Das geht mir so auf den Sack. Und das ist auch noch so ein Pop-up. Und du bist schon dabei, irgendwie in diese Suchmaske irgendwas einzutippen. Und dann machst du... Und dann hast du diesen, ich will keinen 5-Euro-Geschenkgutschein von Amazon.
Ich will nur ein Buch.
Der ist aber besser als zum Beispiel eine Freundin von mir, die mal bei Amazon war und danach ein Thema suchte und auch ein Thema kaufte, was nicht so ganz immer 100 Prozent dezent ist. Kommunismus. Jedenfalls immer, wenn die jetzt auf die Amazon-Seite zurückgeht, wird sie immer mit diesem Thema konfrontiert. Das ist ja natürlich super peinlich.
Geschlechtsverkehr.
Du hast es fast gestern.
Fast Geschlechtsverkehr? Entschuldigung. Was ist bitte fast Geschlechtsverkehr? Das ist ja ekelhaft.
Das ist etwas wie fast Schwangersagen.
Kommt die vom Land? Das sagt mir alles.
Und ich bin ein sehrer Spieler.
Chaosradio, Chaosradio 72 hier auf Fritz. Viel Zeit haben wir nicht mehr, aber wir kriegen das irgendwie geregelt. Wir haben uns natürlich wie immer, wenn wir Chaosradio machen, viel zu viel vorgenommen. Wir hoffen, dass wir bis ein Uhr wenigstens weitestgehend das alles erzählt haben, was wir glauben, dass ihr wissen müsst, um im Leben, in dem ihr ja das eine oder andere Datum rausgebt, klarzukommen. Es ist verblüffend, dass ich bei diesem vergleichsweise langen Satz den Faden behalten habe. Könnte jetzt bitte jemand der kompetenteren...
Sind. Sind.
Sind. Sind. Das weiß Sarah wahrscheinlich noch nicht. Wenn du den Faden verloren hast, hilft... Also wenn du fängst einen langen Satz an, hast du den Faden verloren und sagst dann einfach sind.
Das stimmt zu 80%.
Na 80% weiß ich nicht, aber in mehr als der Hälfte der Fälle. Also zumindest meine meine Privat Empirie, die das mehr oder weniger zutagebracht hat. Also zutage gebracht sind.
Wir waren stehen geblieben beim Internet. Apropos Internet, nochmal unsere E-Mail Adresse, nämlich 72 at chaosradio.ccc.de und das ist genau für diese Sendung und für die nächste Sendung nehmt ihr bitte die 73 at chaosradio.ccc.de Gesundheit. Für allgemeine Anfragen könnt ihr auf chaosradio.edfritz.de Und wartet aber bitte noch, wenn ihr noch irgendwie URLs haben wollt oder irgendwelche interessanten Sachen noch ein, zwei Tage, dann schicken wir dir ein Chaos Update drum und da stehen auch nochmal so die ganzen wichtigen URLs, die wir jetzt hier so am Abend auch für die Recherche benutzt haben. Internet, wir haben gerade schon ein bisschen was gehört zu so Clickstream Analysen, Logfiles, IP-Adressen und auch Datensammlungen über Cookies und der Trend geht auch weiterhin weiter zur Authentifizierung, also zur Personalisierung von Seiten. Das heißt, ich soll mich dann anmelden für ein Newsletter oder eben auch, dass ich persönlich angepasste Menüs bekommen kann oder spezielle Navigationselemente, die meinem Wunsch entsprechend angepasst werden. Und darüber wird dann versucht, dem Nutzer, der kommt, eine wiederkehrende Identität auch zuzuordnen. Also das ist vielleicht, Sie wissen nicht direkt meinen realen Namen, aber Sie können mich auf jeden Fall auch wieder identifizieren. Dass das Internet als Datensammelpool irgendwie ganz gut in Mode gekommen ist, hat wahrscheinlich jeder auch schon mal irgendwie gemerkt. Wir hatten ja auch letztens eine Sendung über Spam-Mails, irgendwie auch eine ganz tolle Sache. Und es gibt aber ein System, also ein System ist es eine technische Vorrichtung oder wie auch immer, die diese Privatsphäre beim Surfen, beim Bewegen im Internet ein bisschen schützen soll oder die da irgendwie mich warnen soll, wenn da irgendwie was mit meinen Daten passiert, was ich eigentlich so nicht will. Es nennt sich P3P und es ist die...
Wo hinter irgendwie... Hast du noch mal geguckt, welche Firmen alle hinterstecken?
Nee, Firmen nicht, aber... Das ist vom W3C-Consortium, das sind also die, die diese ganzen Webstandards auch verabschieden.
Also im Prinzip ist es ja nur, wir haben ja immer diese Privacy Statements auf Seiten, die kein Mensch durchlässt und kein Mensch versteht. Und ich glaube, die Ur-Idee war das einfach in ein maschinenlesbares Format zu packen.
Richtig.
Und dann hinzugehen und dafür zu sorgen, dass man irgendwie auf jeder Seite so einen Client Agent hat, den man, wo man vorher sagt, also...
Ich hab hier jemanden am Telefon, der sich damit auskennt. Wollen wir den mal fragen?
Achsel.
Ist gut, Alex.
Ach komm.
Erklär uns mal, was das ist. Also was heißt P3P? Heißt noch mal.
Platform for Privacy Preferences. Und macht was? Also jeder, der schon irgendwie im Internet gesurft ist und sich da irgendwie... Also jeder, der schon irgendwie im Internet gesurft ist und sich da irgendwie mal irgendwo ein Vertrag unterschrieben hat, also so ein Pseudo-Vertrag, der hat sich doch immer geärgert, dass da immer so ein kleines Kästchen ist. Und da steht ja endlos viel Text drinne. Auf Englisch. In einem Juristenenglisch, was dann natürlich kein Mensch versteht. Und ja, wie Sarah sagte, die Idee war eigentlich wahrscheinlich, so nehme ich auch mal an, dass sie sich gesagt haben, das müssen wir maschinenlesbar haben, dass das auch ein normaler Mensch lesen kann und dass der Computer das automatisch verarbeiten kann.
Könnte das auch...
Also, sagen kann, passt das zu meiner Identität, so wie ich mit meinen Daten umgehe oder nicht.
Vielleicht sollte damit auch einfach verhindert werden, dass die Leute überhaupt erst mal auf den Gedanken kommen, sich sowas durchzulesen?
Nein, dass die Fenster so klein sind, natürlich. Also, die haben diese Absicht, dass man sie nicht durchlesen kann.
Wie funktioniert das? Also, ich hab das jetzt auf meinem Rechner drauf. Also, so rein installiert, ne?
Ach so, zu dem rein installiert. Also, es war ja gerade die Frage, wer da so alles mitgearbeitet hat. Also, ein großer Vorteil war, ist, dass Microsoft daran mitgeschraubt hat.
Das ist ein Vorteil?
Das ist ein Vorteil. Das ist dreimal ausnahmsweise ein Vorteil, dass jetzt schon im Internet Explorer 6 drin ist. Der benutzt das schon, der macht das schon. Also, ist das schon sehr stark im Kommen, obwohl der Standard erst im Mai, glaube ich, diesen Jahres auf Habschied ist.
Ja, aber wie funktioniert das jetzt? Also, ich nehme dann ein Tool und installiere mir das auf meinen Rechner. Beziehungsweise nehme ich Internet Explorer 6, da ist dieses Tool oder was auch immer das ist schon drin.
Genau.
Und was mache ich dann?
Und dann fängst du an zu klicken. Also, du klickst dich dann in... Ich habe mir das noch nie wirklich angeguckt beim Internet Explorer. Mangelst Windows. Aber so wie das beschrieben ist, klickt man sich da durch und sagt dann einfach, ich hier bin jetzt diese Daten frei, also diese bin ich bereit freizugeben. Und wenn aber andere Daten gefragt sind, wie zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, meine Handy-Nummer, dann sagt sie mir Bescheid, wenn die Seite das verlangen würde. Und dann bekomme ich die Chance, ja oder nein, zu klicken. Möchte ich diese Seite angezeigt haben, möchte ich sie nicht angezeigt haben.
Also ich sage in meinem Browser praktisch vorher, von diesen Daten, die ich dir jetzt eingegeben habe, oder die du theoretisch von mir zur Verfügung hast, darfst du nur das, das und das rausgeben.
Ja, naja. Also nein, es werden nicht automatisch Daten rausgegeben. Das ist wahrscheinlich ein ferneres Ziel, was damit erreicht werden soll. Also auf jeden Fall ist es so, dass er dich warnt, wenn andere Daten abgefragt werden.
Funktioniert das mit jeder Seite, die Daten abfragt?
Nein, das funktioniert noch nicht mit jeder Seite. Die muss extra P3P installiert haben. Also die Leute, die diese Webseite machen, müssen sich einmal hinnehmen, sich ein Tool schnappen. Also es gibt da schon für Tools zum Zusammenklicken von so einer Policy nennt sich das dann, also wo dann drin steht, was für Daten abgefragt werden. Das kann dann relativ einfach auf die Seite gebracht werden und dann benutzt das der Browser automatisch.
Hattest du da nicht so einen tollen Hack in dem Zusammenhang?
Ja, also das wäre dann das nächste. Also leider, also das wird ein Hack. Also es ist einfach, dass ein Problem existiert, dass ich selber mir immer diese Policy holen muss. Ich werte sie aus und sage dann, ob ich das machen möchte oder nicht. Dabei wäre es eigentlich viel andersrum viel schöner, wenn ich hingehe und sage, ich gebe dir maximal diese Daten und jetzt sag mir mal, ob ich jetzt die Seite kriege oder nicht. Und dadurch kommt es erst mal zustande, dass die Webseitenbetreiber sich überlegen, weil so stellen Leute sehr schnell, sehr strikt zusammen, was sie denn eigentlich preisgeben wollen. Also die geben dann relativ wenig frei und dadurch können sich die Webseitenbetreiber sagen, müssen wir halt mit unseren Anforderungen, was wir an Daten sammeln, runtergehen.
Das Problem beim Internet Explorer ist, soweit ich das gesehen habe, dass es da auch ähnlich wie bei den Sicherheitsentstellungen so verschiedene, einfach so drei, vier Levels gibt. Das heißt, ich muss mir leider nicht die Mühe machen zu sagen, okay, Name, Anschrift gebe ich frei, das und das gebe ich nicht frei und vielleicht, naja gut, welche Mobiltelefonen Hersteller ich habe, das können sie ruhig wissen. Sondern es gibt dann auch wieder diese verschiedenen Stufen, wo ich mich eigentlich nicht wirklich damit auseinandersetzen muss. Also es gibt zwar wieder auch Feineinstellungen, aber da muss man sich auch schon sehr, sehr lange mit auseinandersetzen.
Das Krasse ist ja, was Axel auch gerade beschrieben hat. Wenn man das, was der Standard will, was Axel gerade gesagt hat, dass man genau sagen kann, wann gebe ich was von mir Preis? Das ist die Idee. Und wenn man in Explorer 6 reingeht und guckt, was da los ist, dann kann man das gar nicht spezifizieren. Man hat wirklich nur diese Stufen.
Was ich noch viel, viel schlimmer, oder welche Frage ich da irgendwie viel brennender finde, ist, wer hindert beispielsweise Microsoft daran, mir das nur vorzugaukeln?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Die haben wir uns auch schon gestellt. Und die Lösung dabei war, also erstmal hindert ihn niemand daran. Also es hindert niemanden daran zu sagen, wir ziehen erstmal alles an Daten.
Also ich meine, es ist doch im Grunde, kann es mir doch passieren, dass das genau so ein clicky-bunty Ding wird, wie ein 0-190-Deiler, den ich mir aus Unwissen halt irgendwo runter lade.
Ja, der Vorteil an der ganzen Geschichte ist, die Firma gibt ja was von sich preis. Sie sagt ja, wir sammeln diese Daten. Sie sagt ja nicht, nein, sie sagt sogar mehr. Sie sagt nicht nur, wir sammeln diese Daten, sondern wir sammeln diese Daten dafür. Weil es wird in dieser Policy nicht nur angegeben, welche Daten gesammelt werden, sondern sogar wofür. Ob jetzt für administrative Zwecke oder für Bauen der Webseite, damit die Leute wissen, also dieser Clickstream zum Beispiel, wo die Leute lang wandern, um das zu perfektionieren. So wie in einem Kaufhaus, die Wege perfektioniert werden, wo die Leute langgeführt werden an den Produkten. Da steht dann auch drin, wofür die Daten gebraucht werden.
Aber kann ich als Benutzer wirklich vorgeben sagen, ok, die Sachen dürfen jetzt verwendet werden und die nicht?
Ja, also persönliche Berichte kann ich da jetzt noch nicht so zu abgeben. Wie gehört Internet Explorer 6, scheint das nicht so zu tun. Was angedacht ist, also der Internet Explorer 6 bietet die Möglichkeit, sowas zu sich reinzuholen, sprich eine verfeinerte Konfiguration. Die man selber mit dem Internet Explorer aber nicht herstellen kann.
Wird dann P3P in der Praxis jetzt schon verwendet? Wird P3P in der Praxis schon irgendwo verwendet?
Ich hab da mal einen Skript geschrieben, was sich ein bisschen durchs Web hangelt und nicht wirklich viel. Also Microsoft macht das, web.de macht das, Dell und noch ein, zwei, drei, vier andere. Mehr aber auch noch nicht. Also wirklich große Seiten. Also es macht noch nicht die Masse.
Aber du bleibst da dran?
Ich bleib da dran und ich werde also, ich versuch derzeit ein bisschen was loszutreten, dass das auch ein bisschen deutschner verbreitet wird. Mal ein deutsches Handbuch dazuschreiben, ein kurzes How-To wie Leute auf ihre Webseite P3P bringen können, wie sie das richtig machen. Und das wäre ganz schön.
Gib mal eine Webadresse durch, wo man vielleicht ein paar mehr Informationen noch kriegt.
Hast du eine? Also P3P gibt es derzeit noch nicht viel Informationen. Ansonsten ist das www.w3c.org Schrägstrich Groß P3 Groß P.
Auch das wird im Mailing vermerkt werden. Ja, Achmed, Entschuldigung, Birgit, Britta. Vielen Dank für dieses Gespräch. Wir müssen jetzt mal Nachrichten machen. Haben wir doch, dachte ich. Gute Nacht noch. Tschüss. Chaosradio 72 auf Fritz. Die Musik kommt von LN. LN ist eine DJin und sie ist live im Studio und live auch in diversen Städten Deutschlands zu sehen.
Wo?
Das sagen wir euch nachher.
Wenn Fritz im Berliner Kabel. Dann 89, 85.
Mit dem Wetter heute Nacht 12 bis 8 Grad. Vereinzelt Schauertags, heiter bis wolkig, gebietsweise vereinzelt Regen. Es wird Regen, wir wissen nur nicht geben. Maximalwerte morgen 21 Grad. Hier sind die Meldungen mit Kerstin Topp.
Die irakische Luftabwehr hat auf amerikanische und britische Kampfflugzeuge gefeuert, die in der nördlichen Flugverbotszone flogen. Diese Zone wird vom Irak nicht anerkannt. Die Maschinen drehten ab. Die Flugverbotszonen im Norden und im Süden Iraks wurden nach dem Golfkrieg 1991 zum Schutz der kurdischen Bevölkerung eingerichtet. Die Frist für die Schlichtung im Baugewerbe ist verlängert worden. Das teilte der Vorsitzende der Schlichtungskommission Geisler mit. Ursprünglich wäre die Friedenspflicht um Mitternacht abgelaufen. Die Arbeitgeber bieten bisher gut ein Prozent mehr Geld. Die IG BAU will 4, 5 Prozent. Bei Tests in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern sind mit nitrofenbelastete Eier und Geflügelfleisch gefunden worden. Landwirtschaftsminister Backhaus teilte mit. Die Werte erreichten zum Teil das 18-fache des Erlaubten. Er geht davon aus, dass mehrere Zehntausend Legehennen getötet werden müssen. Der Antisemitismusstreit zwischen dem Zentralrat der Juden und FDP Vizepräsident Möllemann ist auch nach dessen Fehlerbekenntnis noch nicht beendet. Zentralratspräsident Spiegel fordert von Möllemann eine persönliche Entschuldigung für seine Äußerung über den Zentralratsvizepräsident Friedman. In den Niederlanden soll die Einwanderungspolitik verschärft werden. Darauf haben sich die Christdemokraten und die rechtspopulistische Liste Pim Forteuen geeinigt. Nach Angaben der Zeitung Allgemeen Dachblatt soll sich die Zahl der Asylbewerber um fast 80 Prozent verringern. Und zum Sport nach zehn Etappen im rosa Trikot hat Telekom Prof. Jens Heppner die Führung im Giro d'Italia abgegeben. Neuer Spitzenreiter ist der Australier Cadel Evans. Die Verkehrsmeldungen A10, Autobahn Dreieck, Potsdam, Schönefelder Kreuz, zwischen Raststätte Michendorf und Drewitz-Nutetal ist die Fahrbahn wegen Bauarbeiten auf einen Fahrstreifen verengt. A9, Potsdam, Halle Leipzig, zwischen Beelitz und Brück ist wegen eines Unfalls der rechte Fahrstreifen gesperrt. Stadtverkehr Berlin A111, Berlin-Charlottenburg, Autobahn Dreieck-Oranienburg, zwischen Kurt-Schumacher-Damm und Tunnelflughafen Tegel derzeit ein Kilometer Stau. Und A100, Wilmersdorf-Lichtenberg im Ortskern Britz ist wegen Bauarbeiten der rechte Fahrstreifen gesperrt.
Fritz hat sie wieder, deine höchstpersönliche Openair Toi-Toi Dixie-Toilette, weil voller Blase nicht hier an Schlange steht. Fritz überträgt wieder live eine ganze Nacht mit Anja Schneider.
Weil so bist du dabei, egal wo du bist.
Das Melt-Openair, Freitag 7. und Samstag 8. Juni in Ferropolis bei Gräfen-Heinichen und im Radio.
Live Samstagabend ab 19 Uhr im Dance Under The Moon Spezial.
Ich. Chaos Radio 72 auf Ritz. Wir haben eine Viertelstunde Zeit, dann müssen wir leider auch auf Ritz. Du warst der, der... Ich hatte vorhin angerufen und habe ein Zitat angefangen, ohne zu sagen, dass es ein Zitat ist, worauf ich gleich rausdrücke.
Bei dem Inhalt auch verständlich.
Der Inhalt war einfach nur ein Zitat.
Einer der vielen SMS, der Art, die ich seit meinem wegen einem Jahr bekomme, seitdem ich einmal im Internet war und irgendwie irgendwo dummerweise meine Handynummer angegeben hab. Und seitdem bekomme ich immer ziemlich brutale, perverse Sex-SMS. So nach dem Motto...
Was war das für eine Seite, wo du deine Nummer angegeben hast?
Das würde ich auch gerne wissen.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Keine Ahnung. Ich muss aus der Zuge stehen.
Ich bin einer der echten Opfer, weil ich wirklich bis jetzt vielleicht 10 Stunden im Internet verbracht hab. Ich bin eigentlich nicht so ein Internet-Rumhänger.
Ich hab es auch abgebaut.
Ich weiß, dass ich noch nie irgendwas richtig zu Ende ausgefüllt hab. Aber ich hab irgendwo mal was eingetragen und dann auch wieder abgebrochen, glaube ich. Aber seitdem bekomme ich unregelmäßig, irgendwie alle ein, zwei Wochen, mal so eine SMS nach dem Motto Hi Süßer. Ist das allein oder was?
Also das ist richtig übel. Ich hab das auch mal gehabt. Hab eine einzige SMS gekriegt, wo dann aber auch so was drin stand, wie du hast gewonnen, ruf zurück, 090 irgendwas. Und hab daraufhin bei E plus angerufen, hab die wirklich angeschrien, was ihnen denn einfällt, meine Daten weiterzugeben, obwohl ich ihnen schriftlich mitgeteilt habe, dass ich das nicht haben möchte.